Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 78. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer tollen neuen Folge. Und ihr wisst schon, wieder gibt es Informationen, die ihr noch nie haben wolltet, aber ich schütte es einfach alles in euch rein. Ihr könnt euch nicht wehren. So ist das hier bei Chaos Radio Express. Und wie es auch immer so ist, gibt es ja immer einen Gast. Das soll heute nicht anders sein. Und ich begrüße Tom. Tom, Tom Lazar. Auch schon seit ewigen Zeiten im Chaos-Umfeld umtriebig. Wir hatten eben gerade schon ein bisschen die Hirne angestrengt, festgestellt, du bist jetzt auch schon fast eine Dekade dabei. Was hat dich denn überhaupt zum Club getrieben?
Mac-Hackers. Vor meiner Liebe zu Unix gab es die Liebe zu Macintosh.
Ist die jetzt schon verblasst?
Es gibt jetzt keinen Unterschied mehr.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ja, genau. Die Mac-Hackers, eine Mailing-Liste, die wir mal einberufen haben, die es auch immer noch gibt, die auch noch sehr umtriebig ist. Kann man gleich mal erwähnen, wer irgendwie Lust hat, mit klugen Leuten über Macintosh zu diskutieren. Ich bin ganz froh, die Liste ist bisher immer noch nicht...
4.059 ungelesene E-Mails auf Mac-Hackers.
Die ist ja immer noch nicht verkommen.
Immer noch die netteste Mailing-Liste der Welt.
Ist sie, ne? Also ich bin auch echt immer wieder erstaunt, wie freundlich es da zugeht. Vor allem die ein-, zweimal, als es mal nicht freundlich zuging, wurden die Jungs aber auch gleich wirklich mit Pocken und Trompeten verjagt. Das war sehr angenehm.
Und sind seither nicht mehr gesehen.
Es gibt sie noch, die soziale Kontrolle im Internet. Ganz neu. So, und ja, wir hatten dann auch mal eine ganz interessante gemeinsame Phase. Auch das soll mal erwähnt werden. Ehre wem Ehre gebührt. Denn du bist ja verantwortlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich da selber noch dran erinnerst.
16C3.
Du hast es mal erfreut. Und ich weiß noch, wie wir irgendwie verzweifelt in diesem Zimmer saßen, vollkommen gerädert nach dem, nach was denn eigentlich war das?
Nach einem Camp? Echlorak? Das erste Camp. Stimmt, richtig.
Nach dem ersten Camp. Genau. Und irgendwie mein Hirn war leer und nichts ging mehr. Und dann bist du mit dieser Idee aufgekommen, den Congress 16C3 zu nennen. Genau. Ja, das hat ganz gut gehalten bisher. Haben wir einfach beibehalten.
Ich denke, das bleibt auch.
Einfach so. Ich denke auch, das verfängt ganz gut. Aber es klang schon durch. Du bist eigentlich ein Mann der Tat. Und Macintosh hast du immer noch, jetzt auch mit Unix. Und du bist, kann man sagen, selbstständig tätig und beschäftigst dich vor allem mit Content-Management-Systemen im Web. Das heißt, du baust Webseiten. Vor allem Webseiten, die viel Inhalt haben. Dir geht es nicht so sehr um die Hübschung. Du bist jetzt kein Designer und Gestalter. Das fällt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen nebenbei noch mit ab, aber...
Für den Hausgebrauch. Ich bin eher der Handwerker, der die Sachen hinzimmert.
Genau. Und das soll auch unser Thema sein. Jetzt haben wir es hier schon lang genug verschleppt. Soap und Plone, das sind zwei eng miteinander verheiratete Begriffe, die wir hier mal ein wenig aufschlüsseln wollen. Das hat sicherlich der eine oder andere schon mal gehört, wer noch nicht gehört hat. Es handelt sich insgesamt hierbei um eine mögliche Lösung, eine umfangreiche Webseite aufzubauen, ein sogenanntes Content-Management-System. Das ist ja ein sehr schwammiger Begriff, schon immer gewesen und daran hat sich eigentlich auch wenig geändert. Jetzt ist Soap und Plone zusammen, bildet so eine Einheit. Vielleicht fangen wir mal mit dem ersten an, da mal einen genaueren Blick darauf zu werfen. Was ist Soap?
Soap ist ein Python-basiertes oder ein Python-geschriebenes Content-Management, oder eigentlich ein Web-Application-Framework. Es ist recht generisch. Es hat eigentlich per se nicht wirklich was mit Content-Management zu tun. Es ist ein Framework und vom Umfang und von der Rangehensweise vergleichbar, was ich mit Ruby on Rails oder Django oder Turbogears.
Das heißt, es bietet sozusagen die Werkzeuge, um eine Web-Anwendung zu schreiben?
Man könnte es grob als CMS-Construction-Kit beschreiben.
Ist es denn dediziert für CMS gedacht oder ist es... Ich meine, Web-Applikation-Framework klingt ja erst mal recht generell.
Es ist recht generell. Es ist zwar schon mit Fokus auf webbasierte Anwendungen und HTTP, aber selbst das müsste nicht unbedingt sein. Es ist sehr modular. Das heißt, es gibt auch Projekte, die Teile von Zope verwenden, die überhaupt keine Web-Anwendungen sind.
Ach, was denn zum Beispiel?
Ich habe jetzt gehört, hier, Mac OS X hat die Zope-Interfaces bei Leopard standardmäßig mit dabei, weil ich glaube, es ist... ist nicht Mambo dabei bei Mac OS X Server als Standard-Blogging-Application. Ich müsste meine auf meinem einen... Es gibt eine Software-Komponent in Mac OS X Server, die in Python geschrieben ist, standardmäßig mit dabei ist und die wiederum die Interfaces von Zope verwendet, was dazu geführt hat, dass wenn man jetzt in einer frischen Zope Mac OS X Leopard-Installation nach Zope greppt, da ist schon Zope mit drin. Aber eben auch nicht das ganze Framework, sondern eben nur der Teil, der die Interfaces für Python zur Verfügung stellt.
Okay, ich weiß es nicht. Aber lass uns erst nochmal bei Zope bleiben. Also Zope ist ein Web-Application-Framework. Es ist geschrieben in Python. Damit verortet es sich natürlich auch ein wenig, weil wir wissen, in so einer Programmiersprache hängt natürlich auch immer so eine Kultur mit dran, eine Kultur von Programmierern. Ich selber arbeite nicht in Python. Ich habe das immer wieder festgestellt, dass die Leute, die sich für Python entscheiden, das ist eine ganz interessante Bereiche ab. Es sind vor allem sehr viele Leute, die Protokollarbeit machen im Web. In Python gibt es alle Protokolle. Man findet irgendwie alles. Das heißt, für die Leute, die es gerne genau nehmen, ist das zum Beispiel schon mal so eine Sprache. Das hast du gesagt.
Wir achten sogar auf Whitespace. Wie viele Korintenkacker kannst du es denn noch machen?
Das mag sein. Aber ich werte das gar nicht. Ich versuche nur so ein bisschen zu finden. Ich hatte ja neulich Chaos Radio Express 72. Da habe ich mich ja hier mit den Jungs von Zope unterhalten. Die verwenden halt Ruby und Rails, was ja eine relativ geschwinde Karriere dahingelegt hat. Erst war Ruby eigentlich mehr so eine Sprache unter vielen. Durch Rails kamen dann eben auch die Sprachen mit rein. Das hat dann eben noch eine ganze Menge Kultur geerbt, so ein bisschen Perl hier, ein bisschen Smalltalk da. Das war eine interessante Gemengelage. Hat sich dann vor allem relativ schnell eben diese Gestalterfront auch sozusagen mit in die Fankurve geholt. Nur ganz interessante kulturelle Dinge, die dahinter gehen. Bei Python sehe ich halt eben sehr viel mehr den seriösen Programmierer. Sehr viele akademische Leute verwenden das halt auch. So, und jetzt frage ich mich halt vor dem Hintergrund, was hat denn das jetzt für eine Auswirkung auf so ein System wie Zope? Ist denn Zope überhaupt so sehr mit der Python-Community verheiratet?
Die Geburtsstunde von Zope ist, glaube ich, nur ein paar Monate entfernt von der Geburtsstunde von Python selbst. Guido van Rossum und Jim Fulton haben viel in der ersten Python-Usergroup, die es überhaupt gab, zusammen, also waren da zusammen. Und insofern haben die beiden wirklich dieselben Wurzeln. Und das ist dann über die Zeit auseinandergedriftet, weil Zope sehr viel eigenes machen wollte, auch musste, weil es es zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht gab. Und hat sich dann so ein bisschen von der Python-Community entfernt. Und wurde dann auch entsprechend mit den Jahren halt von der Python-Community einfach missachtet, so nach dem Motto, it's not Pythonic. Und die Kurve ist jetzt wieder dabei, einen Schwenk zu machen und Zope 3 ist jetzt sozusagen wieder ein Schritt von Zope auf die größere Python-Community hin wieder zu. Und wird wohl auch, also so wie es angenommen wird, ist sehr zuversichtlich, also sind wir sehr zuversichtlich, dass es auch so weitergeht.
Zurück zur Mutti.
Ja, zurück zu den Wurzeln auch so ein bisschen. Python hat ja auch so einen Ansatz, dass es so einfach wie möglich sein sollte. Und das war bei Zope 2 in den Endphasen halt wirklich nicht mehr gegeben. Das ist auch so ein Schritt zurück zu einer Simplifizierung und Vereinfachung. Und ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal gesehen, hier, Cal-Dev-Server ist written in Twisted. Twisted ist ein allgemeines Web-Framework. Und Twisted wiederum benutzt einfach nur Zope.interface. Sonst nichts von Zope. Weil das einfach für die Leute, die Twisted geschrieben haben, halt genau gepasst hat.
Das heißt der Calendar-Server, der Mac OS 10-Calendar-Server, den Apple selber gehackt hat, der bei Leopard mit dabei ist.
Dann haben wir uns ja gut ergänzt.
Die wollte ich ja nochmal ausprobieren. Aber soweit bin ich noch nicht gekommen. Man kommt jetzt von nix. Bleiben wir nochmal bei Zope, dass wir auch das mit Interfaces vielleicht verstehen können. Was bietet denn jetzt dieses Subsystem? Also wenn man jetzt schon hört, es gibt ein Content-Management-System ganz oben drauf, das können wir schon mal vorwegnehmen. Also am Ende landen wir dann eben bei Plone.
Nichts anläufig, aber hier schon.
Genau. Das heißt, man hat jetzt erstmal so ein Fundament, was irgendwie sagt, ok, alles klar, du willst Web-Anwendungen machen, ja, welcher Art auch immer, dann bau doch mal auf uns auf. Was sind denn jetzt so diese Dienste, die da herkommen, die mich davon überzeugen sollen, dass das eine tolle Idee ist?
Zum einen sind es natürlich so die ganzen webbasierten Sachen, wie, also wir hatten, es gibt halt ein Request-Objekt, das Zope zur Verfügung stellt, das ein bisschen reichhaltiger und komfortabler ist als das, was bei Python out of the box dabei ist.
Also mit Request-Objekt meinst du, wenn jetzt, ich bin ein Server und ich werde irgendwie über HTTP angesprochen, dann wird diese Anfrage als Objekt dargestellt?
Genau, das ist dann ein Python-Objekt, wird daraus instanziert, das dann halt eben Interfaces hat, Methoden-Aufrufe, die halt eben dementsprechend, was die allgemeine Spezifikation für so ein Request halt vorsieht, also Response-Header.
Das ist in Python an sich schon drin, aber mit Zope ist das dann noch mal mit Zope oben drauf?
Und das mag man dann durchaus auch zu schätzen. Vor allem so Sachen wie Authentifizierung und eben dann auch ein großes Vorteil oder ein großes Hauptvorteil von dem Zope-Framework ist, dass es halt eben mit Authentifizierung und Benutzerrollen und Rechten halt sehr gut umgehen kann. Also jeder Request wird dann auch automatisch immer durch die Berechtigungsmaschinerie durchgejagt. Es geht gar nicht anders. Und am Schluss wird immer noch entschieden, ob dann überhaupt die Daten rausgerückt werden dürfen oder nicht.
Das heißt, es gibt schon ein Zugriffsschema, ein zugriffsrechte Schema auf der niedrigsten Ebene?
Genau. Das ist eigentlich ein wichtiges Feature, weil häufig ist es so, wenn das CMS bei der Rechteprüfung versagt, wenn der Pferdner dich sozusagen schon ins Gebäude eingelassen hat und alle Türen sind offen und wenn du einmal am Pferdner vorbei bist, kannst du tun und lassen, was du willst. Das ist dann halt natürlich ein zusätzliches Problem. Und um es so zu vergleichen, ist bei Zope nicht nur ein Pferdner am Eingang, sondern jede einzelne Tür hat nochmal jemand, der auf deine Karte guckt und sagt, darfst du überhaupt hier in dieses Archiv rein oder nicht. Und die meisten Content-Management-Systeme, die haben halt einen Datenbank-User und der darf dann halt auf alle Daten zugreifen in der Datenbank und die Applikation prüft, ob der Request zuverlässig ist oder nicht. Und wenn man dann irgendwas hat mit Code Injection, SQL Injection, die dann dafür sorgt, dass wenn der Zugriff erstmal gestattet ist, dass dann auch Daten aus der Datenbank ausgelesen werden, für die ich nicht die Rechte habe, das ist prinzipiell konzeptionell halt mit der Zope-Datenbank nicht möglich. Was die Sache auch langsam macht.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein Overhead. Man verheiratet sich natürlich dann in dem Moment, wo man sich für Zope entscheidet, dann wahrscheinlich auch mit sehr viel schon mal grundlegenden Annahmen und abstrakten Konzepten. Das muss ja auch nicht jetzt unbedingt jedermanns Freude sein.
Nee, es ist auch eine steile Lernkurve, das ist schon auch ein bisschen mit Schmerz involviert.
Das heißt, man muss da überhaupt erst mal eine Menge begreifen.
Wenn man es wirklich als Framework benutzen will. Wir greifen, wir wollen ja später nochmal auf Plone zurückkommen, das weiter oben drauf setzt. Und das macht es halt vielen Leuten leicht, diese Vorteile zu genießen, ohne eben diesen Schmerz.
Okay, dann bleiben wir aber erst mal bei dem Schmerz. Wie ich schon in einem der letzten Podcasts festgestellt habe, wir füllen ja das Internet hier mit unserer Sprache. Da ist ja eine Menge Platz, also kann man das auch mal darlegen. Ja, was kommt noch dazu? Also, Zope steht ja für Z, Object, Publishing, Environment. Das heißt, man publiziert Objekte, sprich, die objektorientierte Natur von Python, die in der Programmiersprache schon zu finden ist, findet sich hier auch wieder und wird im Prinzip auf eine andere Ebene gestellt. Das heißt, man kommuniziert auch über das Web schon objektorientiert. Siehst du das richtig?
Genau, es gibt auch die Objekte-Hierarchies. Das ist eben hierarchisch mit einem Root-Objekt und dann mit verschiedenen Kinder-Objekten. Und das wird auch eins zu eins auf die URL zum Beispiel abgebildet. Das ist das Standard-Publishing. Die URL, die ich habe, entspricht dann genau den IDs auch der Objekten. Also der Publisher geht dann einfach durch die Objekthierarchie durch anhand der URL und schaut jedes Mal nach, ob es da was gibt.
Also das Zope dann auch schon eine ganze Menge Vorgaben macht, wie URLs in meinen Anwendungen überhaupt strukturiert sein.
Out of the Box, ja. Also es gibt praktisch einen, ich weiß nicht, wie das dann bei Django oder so was ist, wie dieses Mapping, URL-Mapping. Es gibt praktisch ein Default-URL-Mapping, und das man sich in der Regel dann gar nicht kümmern muss. Und natürlich kann man auch seinen eigenen Traverser schreiben und das dann entsprechend anpassen, aber man muss es nicht.
Okay, das heißt, es ist auch so ähnlich wie bei Rails. Man sagt also, wir bringen jetzt schon mal, also du kannst eigentlich, wenn du möchtest, kannst du alles machen, wie du willst, aber wir würden dir mal empfehlen, hier mit einem Satz von Konventionen einfach mal loszustarten, weil wir haben uns da schon mal Redaktion gemacht und wir sind sowieso klüger als du. Und vielleicht wirst du damit ja auch glücklich. Und ja, so und was sind das jetzt für Objekte, die durch Soap erschaffen werden, die ich dann benutzen kann? Also wir hatten jetzt eben schon dieses Request-Objekt, dabei wird es ja wohl nicht bleiben. Also wie abstrakt ist diese Soap-Welt an der Stelle?
Ja, im Prinzip beliebig. Es gibt so ein paar Annahmen. Also es wird zum Beispiel der sogenannte Dublin Metadata Core wird unterstützt. Dublin Core, genau. Der ist zum Beispiel da mit drin verbacken. Also jedes Soap-Objekt erfüllt auch diese Info. Das heißt, es gibt so etwas wie einen Titel und eine ID und eine Datum und so weiter. Das sind so Annahmen. Es gibt dann so einen praktischen Basis Simple Object, von dem das abgeleitet wird. Das bringt sowas dann schon mit sich.
Also sind Soap-Entwickler Fans des semantischen Webs?
In zwar für zwei Jahre.
Also wir müssen das mal fragen. Dublin Core wird nicht jedem was sagen. Das kann man vielleicht noch mal kurz erwähnen. Dublin Core ist so das Grund-Abezeh des semantischen Webs. Das ist der erste Versuch, überhaupt auch erst mal so eine Ist-Situation zu schaffen, was wir beschreiben, grundlegende Dinge und was sie bedeuten. Also Datum und so eine Sache und eben so Titel und was weiß ich, was ist ein Creator.
Ein Autor, Creator, Contributor, Copyright.
Weil das ja irgendwie in tausend Sachen immer wieder doppeldeutig und überschneidend gehandhabt wird. Da ist Dublin Core ein erster Ansatz gewesen, um da überhaupt erst mal Typen zu schaffen. Okay, sowas fließt hier mit ein. Das ist nachvollziehbar. Jetzt gibt es ja aber auch eine recht innovative Methode, überhaupt Dinge zu speichern. Also mit dieser Persistenz.
Was hat es denn da auf sich? Die Wurzeln von Zopes waren eben zum einen mit dem Object Publisher, also das OP in dem Zope. Und das andere war eben die Object Persistenz. Das war die erste Version, die Urversion von Zope, die genau diese beiden Features ergeben hat. Das heißt, wir benutzen von out of the box keinen SQL als Backend. Und wir haben auch keine Object Relation Mapper. Für den Zope-Entwickler hat er einfach den Luxus, seine Python-Objekte sind einfach von Haus aus persistent und muss sich sonst nicht weiter darum kümmern. Man kann sich dadurch mehr auf die Applikation konzentrieren als jetzt auf irgendwelche Blocks.
Das heißt, im Gegensatz zu Frameworks wie Rails und ich glaube auch Django, also den allermeisten, fast allen wahrscheinlich, geht es erstmal nicht nur darum, die Web-Anwendung zu abstrahieren und dann irgendwie so eine populäre SQL-Datenbank darunter zu packen, sondern auch schon das Speichern aller Daten wird komplett mit übernommen. Und dazu gibt es dann diesen, wie nennt sich das, diese Soap-Database. Und das sind die persistente Objekte.
Genau. Das sind letztendlich einfach nur, Python hat, wie glaube ich, fast alle Sprachen, die Möglichkeit, Pickles, also Daten-Konstrukte zu picklen. Das heißt, es wird einfach die Instanz einer Klasse oder einfach nur auch eines Grundobjektes, einer Zahl, wird einfach in den String umgewandelt. Und diesen String kann ich jederzeit wieder zurück umwandeln.
Pickle nennt man das da? Ich kenne das nur als surrealisieren, etwas technischerer Begriff.
Python ist ja nicht nach der Schlange benannt worden, sondern nach der Komikertruppe. Und das schlägt sich auch in vielen Wortwendungen auch nieder. Also was zum Beispiel die CPAN Library in Perl ist, das ist bei uns natürlich der Cheese Shop.
Also das Online-Repository, wo man fertige...
Genau, wo alle Module abholen kann.
Okay, Parrot Sketch not included. Aber nochmal zu dieser Persistenzgeschichte. Das ist ja seit ich denken kann, ist das ein heißes Eisen in der Programmierung. So dieses, wie speichere ich eigentlich meine Daten? Und da gibt es irgendwie zwei Fraktionen. Die einen sind halt so die alte Schule. Ja, halt Relationale Datenbank. Jetzt kann man ja nicht gerade behaupten, dass das kein erfolgreiches Konzept ist. Hat sich durchaus bewährt. Das habe ich auch so als der absolute Standard durchgesetzt. Mit anderen Worten, man abstrahiert seine Daten in Tabellen, die zueinander Relationen haben. Und was auch immer man dann in seinem Programm sozusagen vorhält und was man eben auch gerne speichern möchte, das muss man dann eben in diese Relation reinkriegen. Und das ist für einfache Sachen ist das irgendwie ganz übersichtlich. Aber wer das schon mal so gemacht hat, irgendwann kommt man dann doch ganz schön ins Taumeln mit irgendwie Keys und Tralala und was jetzt irgendwie auf was verweist. Und dann braucht man für alles irgendwelche IDs und dann muss man die irgendwie...
Es hängt im Prinzip vom Anwendungsfall ab. Und da wir ja vorhin schon erwähnt hatten, Dokumenten oder content-zentrische Web-Anwendungen, in solchen Fällen kommt man eher ins Schleudern. Also gerade wenn man eben hierarchische Strukturen abbilden will, also was man landläufig halt unter Ordnern und Dateien halt kennt vom Explorer oder vom Finder. So etwas lässt sich halt objektorientiert relativ gut abbilden, weil man im Prinzip einfach nur Container und Content unterscheidet. Also es gibt halt Ordner und die können wiederum andere Ordner enthalten oder am Schluss die Blätter an den Bäumen sind dann halt Dateien, PDFs oder Websites.
So, das heißt, wie muss ich mir das jetzt vorstellen, wenn ich mit Zope eine Web-Anwendung machen will? Das heißt, ich nehme ganz normal, ich programmiere das alles in Python und dann finde ich von der Zope DB so eine Objektwelt vor, die ich verwende, um meine Web-Anwendung zu schreiben. Womit fängt denn das an? Ist dann ein Webserver mit eingebaut in das Zope-System?
Ein Webserver ist eingebaut, der ist zurzeit noch fest eingebaut, wird aber gerade rausgerüttelt, also austauschbar gemacht. Da werde ich gleich noch mal drauf zurückkommen. Zum anderen ist konzeptionell, hat natürlich jede Zope-Datenbank ein Root-Objekt, an dem alles hängt. Weil es eben eine Objekthierarchie ist, die eine Spitze hat, so wie jedes Dateisystem eben auch ein Root hat. Und an dem kann ich mich ganz stumpf entlanghangeln, einfach über die Klassennotation, das ist halt die Punktnotation, foo.bar.tralala, das ist die Fußgängermethode. Und in der Regel will man natürlich Abfragen gestalten, also hole mir das Objekt, den User, mit der IDX oder alle Events, die vor dem 24.12. stattgefunden haben. Dafür gibt es halt einen Utility, einen Katalog, der halt eine API hat, mit dem ich sowas abfragen kann. Und das ist so ähnlich dann halt wie SQL, so select, where, foo, gleich, bar. Und auch im Referenzen kann ich sagen, ok, dieses Objekt zeigt auf einen Freund, dieser User hat einen Freund und einen Freund vom Freund, und dann kann ich diese Referenzen halt entlanghangeln. So etwas, so kann man sich das ungefähr vorstellen.
Und Teil dieses Objektmodells ist auch das Persistenzmodell dieser Soap-Datenbank.
Genau, diese Objekte sind alle, leiten sich von der Persisten-Class ab, das ist so eine ganz basale Klasse, die sich eben dafür sorgt, dass alle abgeleiteten Objekte dann eben auch persistent sind.
Aber wann wird denn jetzt von der Soap-Datenbank dann ein Wert auch wirklich gespeichert? Also in dem Moment, wo ich meinem Objekt irgendeinen Attribut zuweise?
Dann passiert das schon.
Dann ist das sofort auf der Platte.
Genau, es gibt Ausnahmen, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Member einer Liste direkt verändere, dann kriegt das das nicht unbedingt mit. Und es wird erst beim nächsten Schreibzugang dann halt mit draufgeschrieben. Und man kann das dann durch sozusagen ein explizites Commit, kann man das dann auch eben forcieren. Also da gibt es Stellen, wo man als Anwender dann doch darauf achten muss, wo es vorkommen kann, dass es vielleicht nicht sofort gespeichert ist. Aber in der Praxis hat man als Anwender damit als Entwickler, der Anwender ist in dem Fall der Entwickler, der halt die Soap-DB benutzt, damit nichts zu tun.
Jetzt ist ja Soap, hat ja auch so seinen Weg gegangen zu der aktuellen Version, Version 3. Version 3 ist ein kompletter Riefreit.
Genau, mittlerweile sind die Soap-Entwickler, die Core-Entwickler schon fast ein bisschen unglücklich, dass sie das, was sie da gemacht haben, Soap 3 nennen, also dass überhaupt Soap drauf steht. Was passiert ist, ist, dass Jim Fulton ursächlich 2003 angefangen hat zu sehen, das ist zwar alles ganz schön, aber Soap 2 ist monolithisch, es ist immer größer geworden, es platzt aus allen Nähten und es ist unübersichtlich und da ist viel altes Zeugs drin. Und er wollte einfach einen sauberen Schnitt machen und hat angefangen, praktisch die Ideen, die Soap 2 gut gemacht haben und die er auch beibehalten wollte, neu zu implementieren und die Erkenntnisse, die in den vergangenen sieben Jahren gemacht wurden, die eben anzuwenden, aus diesen Fehlern auch zu lernen. Und das kann man so ein bisschen vergleichen, wie die Situation, die Apple hatte Ende der 90er, als sie irgendwie gemerkt haben, wir haben mit Mac OS, damals 8 und 9, sind wir zwar immer noch ganz weit vorne, aber die anderen holen uns ein und irgendwie kommen wir aus unserer Situation nicht einfach so heraus, wir müssen jetzt einfach mal Zöpfe abschneiden und neue anfangen und das ist natürlich einerseits ein bisschen mutig, weil man auch die eigene Userbase halt entfremdet und vor den Kopf stößt und da waren halt Tim Fulton und Konsorten halt einfach auch entsprechend radikal und haben gemeint, hier geht es um die Sache.
Waren denen das denn selber klar oder mussten sie das erst schmerzlich erleiden, dass dieser Rewireit notwendig ist?
Ich glaube schon, dass da gehörig eigene Schmerzen dabei waren. Also das sind ja auch Leute, die dann eben ihr Lebensunterhalt damit verdienen, große Soap-Installationen für größere Kunden im Corporate-Bereich zu implementieren. Das sind die Leute, die den Schmerz natürlich zuerst spüren, wenn du 40.000 User in einer Soap-Datenbank hast. Und dann auf einmal irgendwie...
Und wie leichtgewichtig ist so ein Soap?
Ich glaube trotz allem Rewrite ist das Wort leichtgewichtig nicht was einem zu Soap einfällt. Also es ist natürlich viel besser geworden, aber vor allem ist es auch viel modularer geworden. Das heißt, ich muss nicht irgendwie gleich ein paar Megabyte Soap-Application-Server mit ins Boot nehmen, wenn ich nur ein paar bestimmte Aspekte davon verwenden will. Also das Motto, unter dem auch der Soap-Rewrite stand, war Soap must explode. Also dass es in so kleine Einzelteile zerfällt. Und früher war es auch so, dass Soap an sich auch schon eine minimale Applikation war. Die konnte man starten und man konnte sich in einen Out-of-the-Box-Soap einloggen und auch Objekte hinzufügen. Das war so ein ganz minimalistisches Web-Publishing. Und selbst das ist heute nicht mehr so. Es ist eigentlich nur noch ein Framework. Aber selber an sich keine Applikation mehr. Also Zope, die Applikation ist sozusagen verschwunden. Hat sich rausgekürzt, weil man gemerkt hat, es gibt bessere Applikationen, die das machen, unter anderem eben auch Plone. Und an der Front muss sozusagen nicht weiter krampfhaft noch gearbeitet werden.
Das heißt, man versucht sich sozusagen auf die Kernfunktionalität auch zu beschränken. Das heißt, die Kernfunktionalität hat man ja bisher schon, steckt vor allem erstmal in den Bereitstellen dieser Kernklassen, was du meinst, was bei Ruth anfängt, vor allem die Persistenz der Database, die einen sozusagen von SQL vollständig unabhängig macht.
Genau, und direkt der nächste Schritt ist einfach schon das rechte Management, nämlich um auf diese persistenten Daten zuzugreifen beim Lesezugriff. Auf diese Daten ist immer zwangsläufig auch die rechte Maschine mit am Werk. Und jeder Zugriff folgt halt im Kontext eines Users, das ist halt im Zweifelsfall defaultmäßig der Anonymous. Und dem wurden halt über Konfiguration gewisse Rechte zugeteilt und jeder Zugriff wird gegen diese Rechte abgeprüft. Es ist halt rollenbasiert, es gibt den Reader, den Writer, einen Manager und einen Reviewer zum Beispiel, ist das standardmäßig mit dabei. Man kann aber beliebig für die jeweiligen Applikationen halt selber welche erfinden. Und die Rechte sind halt View, Manage. Es gibt auch einen Unterschied zwischen Manage-Blog, Post und ein allgemeines Manage. Also jede Applikation bringt in der Regel noch ihre eigenen Rechte mit, damit man schön granular unterscheiden kann, ok, dieser User darf zwar die Startseite editieren, aber eben nicht Blog-Posts erstellen zum Beispiel. Und das wird dann noch, das wächst dann. Also jede Applikation bringt eigentlich ihre eigenen Rechte mit, damit man die möglichst feingliedrig granular einstellen kann.
Und gibt es da halbwegs objektive Betrachtungen, wie performant dieses Soap-Database tatsächlich ist?
Es gibt zunehmend mehr anzunehmende Benchmarks. Bis jetzt war das einfach so, die haben Soap in seiner eigenen Welt gespielt. Da gab es dann nicht so direkt die Vergleiche. Es hat natürlich Performance-Einbußen, weil ja eben jeder Zugriff gegen die Security abläuft, zwangsläufig.
Da sprichst du, glaube ich, einen echt interessanten Punkt an. Weil ich kenne das auch so, hier bei zum Beispiel unsere Entwicklung, hier Peterbuff, das Konferenzplanungssystem, was ja in Ruby und Rails entwickelt wurde. Da hat man wirklich dieses Problem, dass man irgendwann anfängt, Rechte zu verwalten, aber ebenso im Kontext der eigenen Anwendung. Man hat halt Benutzer und dann müssen die auf die Daten zugreifen. Dann hat man eine riesige Konflute an mehr oder weniger privaten Daten und will natürlich dann unterscheiden, der darf jetzt irgendwie das und das sehen, der darf das und das sehen. Dann muss man halt, dass sich sozusagen alles nochmal selber bauen und es dann auch noch selber auf das SQL umsetzen.
Und auch noch testen.
Und auch noch testen. Und dann kommt noch eine Änderung rein und dann hast du... Das heißt, das ist etwas, was bei Zope quasi kostenlos dazukommt.
Richtig. Und es nervt einen immer wieder, weil es ein häufiges Phänomen bei der Entwicklung ist, dass ich in der Anwendung, die ich schreibe, einen bestimmten Zugriff erlaube. Und gehe davon aus, ja, das hat schon seine Richtigkeit. Und dann debugge ich es und ich merke, Security Exception. Der User hat diesen Zugriff gar nicht. Also ich greife in meiner Applikation auf etwas zu, von dem ich eigentlich ursprünglich mal gesagt habe, das geht gar nicht. Und jetzt kriege ich es halt um die Ohren gehauen. Jetzt muss ich überlegen, ja, gebe ich jetzt den Zugriff? Oder mache ich hier etwas, was ich eigentlich gar nicht will? Weil ursprünglich sollte er auf diesen Wert gar nicht zugreifen, wenn er in diesem Zustand ist. Und es ist häufig so, dass man dann anfängt, so lustig vor sich hin zu programmieren. Und dann am Schluss, wenn man es dann wirklich through the Web testet, merkt, okay, hier muss ich noch die Security einschalten. Also muss ich ihm einen Zugriff geben, dem Anonymous-User. Oder ich merke, der dürfte die ID hier gar nicht sehen. Also man kriegt es ständig um die Ohren gehauen, weil die SoapDB halt streng ist.
Das heißt, die SoapDB funktioniert eigentlich fast schon mehr wie so ein Web-Betriebssystem?
Kann man so vergleichen, ja.
Weil das ist ja auch das, was beim Betriebssystem, das ist natürlich nicht der einzige Aspekt, aber vor allem bringen ja Betriebssysteme eben so die Sicherheit voreinander. Multi-User-Betriebssysteme. Genau, und hier geht es sozusagen besonders gut geeignet für Multi-User-Webanwendung.
Genau, und das ist halt eben ACL-basiert, nicht einfach nur irgendwie meine Standard-Dateiattribute, sondern ich kann mir beliebig komplexe Rollensituationen und Rechte halt eben selber stricken.
ACL, also Excess-Controles, das heißt, man hat nicht nur irgendwie so darf lesen, darf schreiben, dralalala, sondern für jeden Fall kann man sagen, und hier darf dieser User, darf das machen, diese Gruppe darf das aber nicht machen und so weiter. Na ja, okay, ist das eigentlich überhaupt noch übersichtlich irgendwann?
Das ist auch, dass das in Soap 2 halt gewachsen ist. Du hast dann, wenn du in dem Web-Interface dazu, in dem Management-Interface guckst, hast du dann eine riesen Latte von teilweise sehr obskur benannten Rechten, die aus historischen Gründen noch drin sind. Dieser Zopf wurde mit Soap 3 einfach abgeschnitten. Und da wurde einfach einmal gehörig aufgeräumt. Und für die meisten Sachen braucht man ja auch, also wenn du ein frisches CMS schreibst, brauchst du ja auch nicht von Haus aus 1000 verschiedene Rechte. Und auch wirklich nicht so viele Rollen.
Okay, jetzt hast du ja gesagt, es ist ein Webserver drin, aber man kann ihn auch viel austauschen. Jetzt will ich aber dann doch erst nochmal dabei bleiben, dass einer drin ist, weil ich finde das ja an sich eine coole Funktion. Aber der ist eigentlich mehr so zum Testen und Entwickeln gedacht.
Ursprünglich nicht, mittlerweile halt eben doch. Vor allem weil man heutzutage ja auch nie eine Web-Anwendung nackt ins Internet hängt, sondern immer irgendwie einfach nur aus Performance-Gründen, vielleicht zum Beispiel ein Apache oder ein Lighty oder ein Nginx davor hängt, um zum Beispiel die statischen Ressourcen auszuliefern. Das muss ja nicht durch, wenn ich ein GIF ausliefere für das Logo, das muss ja nicht unbedingt noch durch Python interpretiert werden. Das kann ich ja auch einfach direkt ausliefern. Das heißt, man hängt einen webserver davor und konfiguriert bestimmte statische Bereiche, die werden dann direkt vom Fallsystem ausgeliefert.
Okay, es sei denn, das GIF ist jetzt ein generiertes Ding.
Genau, ein Capture oder sowas, dann würde man das natürlich aus der, aber bestimmte Sachen, von denen man weiß, CSS-Ressourcen, JavaScript-Ressourcen oder so, die kann man dann zum Beispiel auch einfach sagen, okay, das wird jetzt vom Fallsystem ausgeliefert. Aber was Zope damals eben auch schön entwicklerfreundlich gemacht hat, ist, du schmeißt das Ding an und hast sofort deinen Standard-Port 8080 und kannst direkt loslegen und kannst gegen diesen Server hinentwickeln.
Das heißt, du jetzt rein, während man nur Development macht und man hat irgendwie meistens nur einen User, nämlich sich selber, spricht gar nichts dagegen, einfach alles direkt aus dem Zope herauszumachen. Das heißt, da ist ein Webserver mit drin und auf dem kann man dann rumklicken und die ganze Anwendung einfach testen. Und dann gibt es aber, jetzt haben wir es schon gesagt, gibt es halt die Strategien, dass man das mit einem anderen Webserver noch irgendwie kombinieren kann. Jetzt wollte ich nochmal so ein bisschen zurück zu dem, sagen wir das ja mit dem Zope-DB, noch nicht so in epischer Breite ausgesehen. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht nötig, aber was mich nochmal interessieren würde, ist so die Art und Weise, wie man hier jetzt programmiert. Also wie sieht so ein Programm aus? Normalerweise, meine Erwartung wäre jetzt bei so einem Framework, das heißt in dem Moment, wo ich meine Web-Applikation in diesem Zope irgendwie ins Leben rufe, funktioniert die sozusagen schon mal out of the box irgendwie. Sie tut vielleicht erstmal nichts, aber es ist erstmal alles da, was ich brauche. Ich kann einfach einen Webserver anschalten und dann ist die Web-Anwendung sozusagen leer vorhanden.
Es gibt nur dieses Route-Objekt und ein paar Tools.
Das heißt, dann meldet die sich irgendwie an und sagt, jetzt gibt es aber diese und jene URL, auf die würde ich ganz gerne reagieren. Ich freue jetzt einfach mal so doof. Wie fängt man denn an?
Als Plonen-Wirkler hatte ich natürlich ganz andere, noch einen ganz ralaten Rackenschwanz an Assumptions, die Voraussetzungen...
Du hast so ein Event-Modell erwähnt vorhin, was bei Soap eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, das ist auch eine der Kernfeatures, die auch außerhalb von Soap verwendet werden können. Es ist halt so ein Event-Mechanismus, dass ich halt beliebige Events definieren kann und dafür dann halt Listener...
Was für Events sind das?
Standardmäßig oder häufig sind das zum Beispiel, wie ein Objekt wurde veröffentlicht oder es wurde zurückgezogen, es wurde verschoben, es wurde umbenannt, es wurde neu erzeugt. Dann gibt es halt noch so feinere, wie es wurde erzeugt, aber noch nicht in die Datenbank committed. Oder da kann man zum Beispiel dann eben halt Validierung, Validierungscode einhängen, indem man einfach sagt, sich registriert. Und das Framework garantiert, dass alle registrierten Listener dieses Event bekommen haben und ihren Senf dazugeben konnten. Und erst dann, wenn keiner Nein geschrieben hat, dann wird auch dieser Vorgang auch zu Ende geführt. Und der Punkt, bei dem wir das diese Listener, dieses Registrieren, wer fühlt sich jetzt für welches Objekt zuständig und interessiert sich auch dafür, das ist eine Konfigurationsangelegenheit. Das steht nicht im Code, das steht in der Konfigurationsdatei. Das heißt, ich kann einfach durch zwei Zeilen XML, leider XML, aber ich kann halt eben durch zwei Zeilen Konfiguration mich zum Beispiel in den Kern-Publishing-Mechanismus von Zope einhängen und vorher immer noch dafür sorgen, dass halt die Zahl 23 nicht vorkommt. Irgendetwas ganz Profanes, aber es gibt genügend sinnvolle Anwendungen, wo ich wirklich ganz tief in den Mechanismus eingreifen kann, ohne irgendwie in den Basismodulen rumzuvorwerken, sondern einfach, indem ich mich selber noch registriere.
Kann man über die Geschichte auch so, was weiß ich, wenn URLs gespeichert werden, habe ich dann eine Funktion, die immer darauf achtet, dass da kein JavaScript-Code drin steht, um irgendwelche Interpretation zu machen?
Und es ist halt sehr einfach. Und der Code, der das dann wiederum macht, der kriegt einfach das Objekt, um der es sich handelt, den Kontext, den Request, der das ausgelöst hat, und den User, der gerade angemeldet wurde. Das sind einfach so die drei Sachen, die kriegt er so reingeworfen. Und der ganze andere Kontext, das interessiert dann diesen speziellen Code nicht. Der ist dann meistens auch sehr klein. Das sind nur ein paar Zeilen, die halt gucken, ob die URL z.B. bestimmten Kriterien genügt oder nicht.
Jetzt hast du schon ein paar Events aufgezählt. Ich habe die jetzt vergessen, weil wir uns so dieses Pri-Commit...
Basale Sachen, eben Workflow-Änderungen, sprich, es wurde gepublished oder zurückgezogen. Das ist noch eine Sonderform. Da kriegt man dann auch gleich noch die Transition mit. Dann kann man abfragen, wenn das Ding gepublished werden sollte.
Was ist denn für ein Ding?
Das Objekt, der Kontext. Das ist ja auch sehr abstrakt. Das ist z.B. das Basis-Dokument, Objekt by Plone. Das ist halt einfach eine Webseite. Ich erzähle jetzt halt, weil die meisten Beispiele im Plone-Kontext mehr Sinn machen, weil ich dort eine konkrete Anwendung habe. Aber das nimmt sich nichts. Plone hat dieses Event-Modell komplett übernommen.
Da muss es ja, wenn es eine Zope-Anwendung ist sozusagen.
Das können auch nach wie vor die Zope-2-Möglichkeiten noch verwenden. Das geht auch einher.
Diese Events-Geschichte ist z.B. eine Neuigkeit von Zope-3.
Dadurch, dass ich die Event-Content nicht im Code verankern muss und sage, das ist sozusagen push-driven. Ich muss dafür sorgen, dass der Code, der praktisch die Transition durchführt, der für das Veröffentlichen z.B. einer Seite zuständig ist, steht in der Verantwortung, alle wichtigen Mitglieder auch noch zu involvieren. Und zu sagen, jeder muss seinen Selbstwissen zugeben. Das ist sozusagen push. Wenn ein neues Produkt kommt, ein Third-Party-Modul, das auch mitspielen will, dann müsste es sich eigentlich per Patch in diesen Code reinschummeln, damit es auch mitkriegt. Das neue Modell ist natürlich pull-driven. Der Dispatcher selbst schreibt einfach, ja, Objekt X wurde gepublished. Wen es interessiert, der möge jetzt bitte schweigen, was sagen oder für immer schweigen. Und jedes Third-Party-Modul-Produkt kann sich dann da zum Schluss mit dranhängen.
Ich würde sagen, wir bleiben gleich mal bei Soap 3, weil ich denke, dass Soap 2 schon so ein bisschen Schnee von gestern ist. Das ist vorbei. Gut, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt noch keinen Plon verwende, vielleicht wollen wir das ja auf jeden Fall tun, aber jetzt mal nur Soap ist ja ein Publishing-Environment, das heißt, es selbst reicht irgendwie aus, es bietet mir irgendwie eine Menge Features, ich kann da irgendwie ein Path programmieren, ich habe von vornherein ein persistentes System, eine Datenbank, ich brauche kein SQL, ich brauche mir auch keine Gedanken darüber machen, wie meine Datenbank aufgebaut ist, meine Datenbank ist so aufgebaut wie meine Objekte, das sind meine Objekte und sonst einfach gar nichts. Ich kann, es ist ein Webserver mit drin, ich kann auf Anfragen von außen, also Request, einfach irgendwie reagieren, schützt man, dann kriege ich so dieses Request-Objekt, da steht dann drin, was das für ein Request war, ob das jetzt ein Get oder ein Put oder was auch immer war, mit einer URL und dann kann ich halt irgendwie darauf reagieren und außerdem kann ich noch auf sonstige Dinge, die so auftreten, in Abhängigkeit von, reagieren durch dieses Event-Modell.
Und ich kann auch selber welche auslösen. Das denkt man erstmal, man sieht sich da nur als Konsument, aber ich habe auch, weiß nicht, Beispiele neulich, eine Anwendung geschrieben, das war so ein Kampagnen-Management-Tool und da gab es dann eben noch, wenn eine Kampagne bezahlt wurde. Und da mussten halt bestimmte Sachen passieren, unter anderem eine Rechnung rausgeschrieben werden und das Modul, das dann dafür sorgt, das hat einfach nur sich für dieses Event, das ist zu dem, das ich selber erfunden habe. Das wird halt ausgelöst, immer wenn da dieser Bezahlvorgang stattgefunden hat. Und das sorgt dann dafür, dass dann die Rechnung generiert wird. Aber das ist nicht selber im Code, das ist jetzt nicht ein Programmcode, der sagt, ok, jetzt bezahlen wir das und jetzt rufen wir das Rechnungsmodul auf, sondern das eine ist nur fürs Bezahlen zuständig und das andere ist nur dafür, die Rechnung zu schreiben. Und der Kit, der die beiden zusammenhält, ist halt in der Konfiguration, wo ich sage, ok, dieser Händler, der Rechnungen erstellen kann, der abonniert sich auf das Event sein.
Ja gut, dadurch können natürlich diese Events auch schon ziemlich mission-critical sein. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo dieser Event zugestellt werden soll, darf der auch nicht verloren gehen. Was ist, wenn jetzt zwischendurch die Büchse hochgeht?
Dafür sorgt das Framework, dass das praktisch, wie nennt sie das, atomar eben von stattgeht. Entweder geht das alles komplett durch oder alles wurde wieder komplett revert.
Das heißt, es gibt da auch ein Transaktionsmodell?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, klar. Das sind so Sachen, die ich sozusagen für selbstverständlich finde.
Jaja, genau, deswegen versucht er es gerade nochmal herauszuarbeiten. Das heißt, generell jetzt in Soap? Und schon immer?
Ja.
Das heißt, wenn fängt die Transaktion, ist sie dann irgendwie implizit?
Die beginnt mit der Erstellung des Requests.
Ah, das heißt, jemand klickt?
Dein Browser schickt einen Request ab, das kommt beim Webserver an. In dem Moment wird praktisch der Point gesetzt. Und ab dem Moment geht das entweder alles durch oder die Änderungen, die bis dahin passiert sind, werden nicht committed. Ja, aber es ist ungeheuer praktisch, weil man sich in der Regel kaum um so etwas kümmern muss. Es gibt zum Beispiel Momente, wenn ich an einer SQL-Datenbank angebunden bin. Da musste ich zum Beispiel einen Log in eine SQL-Datenbank reinschreiben für eine andere Anwendung. Das will ich natürlich nur dann tun, wenn die Aktion durchgegangen ist. Es gibt das SQL-Framework SQL Alchemy. Das macht sowas auch transparent. Das heißt, wenn mein Zope-Request nicht committed wird, dann macht das automatisch auch noch einen Rollback im SQL, falls ich zwischendurch irgendwas mit SQL angefasst habe. Das heißt, wenn am Schluss festgestellt wird, diese Änderung kann doch nicht durchgehen, dann wird auch automatisch ein Rollback für den Log-Eintrag in der SQL-Datenbank. Weil es diesen Event ja dann auf einmal nicht mehr gibt.
Das heißt, da sollten wir auch nochmal erwähnen, also SQL ist zwar nicht nötig, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass es verbannt ist und man kann SQL natürlich verwenden. Es gibt ja auch genug Datenbanken, auf die man dann wahrscheinlich nochmal zugreifen möchte oder muss. Was mir jetzt noch so aus dem Kopf einfällt, was ja viele Web-Frameworks so mit drin haben, sowas wie Session-Management, ist das auch etwas, was Soap schon bereitstellt? Das ist auch, jetzt wurde es erwähnt, ich fände es auch wieder so eine der Sachen, die du vollkommen selbstverständlich hältst.
Genau, ich kann einfach auf Session zugreifen, ich habe einen Session-Punkt, irgendwas, und das ist dann halt da. Das ist standardmäßig cookie-basiert, und das kann man natürlich auch entsprechend konfigurieren.
Und das hat dann welche Auswirkungen auf meinen Programm-Code? Das heißt, es gibt immer sozusagen auch noch so einen Kontext, in welcher Session ich mich befinde, und den kann ich abfragen, wenn ich möchte.
Ja. Also Request.Session, das wird dann einfach eingebunden.
Das hat man ja auch schon, das heißt auch so der User leitet sich davon ab, ist eingeloggt, ist die Session und so weiter. Ja, vielleicht noch ein letzter Punkt, nochmal so zu diesem Webserver. Wie ist denn das, wenn man so mit HTTPS und SSL arbeiten will? Macht einem das Zope das irgendwie auch einfach? Kann man da einfach mal eben SSL einschalten?
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie SSL in Zope direkt gemacht. Das mache ich immer über den Webserver, der davor steht.
Dann lassen wir das einfach mal raus.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das die Domäne von einem Application-Server ist, sondern das ist die Domäne von einem Webserver.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon genug eingeleitet zu Zope, um mal ein Verständnis dafür auch zu machen, was das eigentlich ist, was sozusagen die Grundlage ist. Sehr viel bekannter ist jetzt, also denke ich jetzt mal, dass das bekannter ist, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das für dich bekannter ist, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall ein System, das heißt Plone, und wir haben es ja schon häufig genug erwähnt. Plone ist eine solche Anwendung für Zope, das heißt, sie setzt vollständig auf Zope auf, nimmt sozusagen alles, was bei Zope selbstverständlich ist, das ist auch bei Plone selbstverständlich. Was macht jetzt Plone, was Zope selbst noch nicht kann?
Das ist sozusagen die Brücke zum End-User hin. Das heißt, Zope out of the box macht kaum etwas, das heißt, ich kann das als Framework benutzen, um Applikationen zu erstellen. Und Plone ist halt eine Anwendung, die kann ich installieren, kann ich runterladen, kann ich auch lokal einfach erstmal laufen lassen und kann dann sofort loslegen, mich anloggen und Seiten bearbeiten. Dateien hochladen, User anlegen, halt so dieses Ganze, was man eigentlich im Endeffekt machen will. Also es ist sozusagen endzielgerichtet.
Aber was ist das Ziel? Das Ziel ist jetzt Content-Management-System.
Genau, Content-Management-System ist ein sehr schwammiger Begriff. Nicht der schwammigste, es gibt auch noch Custodrama Relation Management. Oder datenbankbasierte Webserver.
Objektorientierte Programmierung.
Es gibt verschiedene CMS, die verschiedene Definitionen dieses Begriffs erfüllen und deswegen nicht beliebig austauschbar sind.
Aber ein Webserver hat Content und irgendjemand muss den ja mal managen.
Genau, es ist dokumentenorientiert. Ich habe einen Haufen Seiten, die hierarchisch angeordnet sind. Die möchte ich verwalten. Das heißt, ich möchte neue erstellen. Ich möchte auch den Zugriff darauf managen. Solche Dinge. Wir können es vielleicht sogar als Beispiel nehmen. Ein anderes ähnliches Problem wird zum Beispiel durch die Softwaregattung der Wikis gelöst. Da gibt es natürlich auch eine Schnittmenge. Es gibt auch Bereiche, wo das eine wirklich nicht von Vorteil ist. Und ein CMS halt besser geeignet ist. Ich fange mal mit einem historischen Gegenbeispiel an. Wir hatten nämlich mal schon bereits vor 3-4 Jahren, als ich selber auch noch an der Datenschleuder aktiv war und gerade Plone entdeckt habe. Hammer, Nagel. Hey, wir wollen Datenschleuder ins Netz bringen. Ich habe hier so einen Plone-Hammer. Dann ist die Datenschleuder halt ein Nagel. Und das ist zum Beispiel nach hinten losgegangen, weil das war zu starr. Also die Hacker, die auch sonst an der Datenschleuder mitarbeiten, die wollen nicht irgendwelche speziellen Rechte. Die wollen auf alles per se Zugriff haben. Die wollen alles sofort ändern. Und denen kommt es auch nicht groß auf eine Strukturierung an. Und da war ein CMS einfach zu starr. Und wurde dann letztendlich auch einfach durch einen Wiki ersetzt. Da sind die Daten jetzt halt nicht so strukturiert abgelegt. Und dafür musste jetzt halt die Printausgabe immer per Hand mit Copy und Paste aus dem Wiki ins InDesign. Aber das war dann das kleinere Übel letztendlich. Und umgekehrt haben wir jetzt gerade aktuell das Anliegen, dass zum Thema Wahlcomputer eben auch Aufklärung betrieben werden soll. Und zum Beispiel auch Presse eben einfach grund- oder interessierte Bürger grundsätzlich Informationen abrufen können sollen. Und diese Infos wurden jetzt erstmal von einer Gruppe von engagierten Freiwilligen aus dem Chaos-Umfeld halt in einem Wiki gesammelt. So, die Vorhaltenscheidung. Wir wollen was zusammen machen. Irgendwie Wiki aufsetzen, Content rein dampfen.
Beziehungsweise das Bedienstete CDE-Wiki.
Genau, das gab ja schon ein Wiki. Man muss ja nicht immer mal alles aufsetzen. Genau. Und da hatten die dann tatsächlich auch den eigenen Bedarf, das sollte nach außen hin ein bisschen strukturierter vermittelt werden. Und sollten auch mehrere dann, also eigene R-Fahrkreise, sollen dann ihre eigenen Bereiche irgendwie pflegen können. Und da war das so, da war nicht der Wunsch der Vater des Gedanken, so nach dem Motto, ich kann plonen, ich mache jetzt Datenkleider mit Plonen, sondern da sind halt ein paar Chaoten auf mich zugetreten und haben gesagt, können wir uns nicht mal angucken, ob wir das nicht damit machen. Und das Experiment läuft jetzt noch, ist aber eigentlich so weit schon gelungen, dass man jetzt tatsächlich auf wahlcomputer.ctc.de zugreifen kann. Und dort ist halt so eine fast unmodifizierte Out-of-the-Box-Version von Plonen, weil wir wollten jetzt auch den Aufwand minimal halten, am Start. Und das läuft sich wiederum jetzt gerade sehr gut an. Aber das ist auch ein anderer Anwendungsfall. Also da geht es ja gerade darum, eben Struktur und Ordnung in ein größeres Themengebiet reinzubringen.
Okay, nochmal ein bisschen zurückspulen. Plone ist eine dieser Anwendungen, die man mit Zope machen kann. Zope ist ein Web-Applikation-Framework. Plone ist eine solche Web-Applikation. Und der Dienst, der sozusagen von Plonen angeboten wird, ist eine Website......kollektiv zu verwalten... .kollektiv, genau. Also das heißt mehrere Benutzer. Dabei wird natürlich dann auf das Benutzerechtssystem von Zope zurückgegriffen. Leute können sich halt irgendwie einloggen, haben irgendwie einen User, haben Zugriffsrechte. Es gibt andere Leute, die diese Zugriffsrechte verteilen. Und dann baut man so Seiten und man baut sich seine Hierarchie zusammen, der Website. Das heißt, wenn man das einmal begriffen hat, kann man selbstständig webbasiert die Website selber erweitern, in ihr drin schreiben und so weiter.
Und eines der Ansprüche, die Plone hat, ist, dass es behauptet, userfreundlich zu sein. Das heißt, man kann, es war vielleicht ein bisschen nicht politisch korrekt, aber für mich hat sich der Begriff Hausfrauenkompatibel eingeprägt, weil ich bereits vor ein paar Jahren für einen gemeinnützigen Verein, ein Museum, klingendes museum.de, da Plone als CMS aufgestellt habe, weil die ehrenamtlich betreut wurden. Das waren tatsächlich zwei Hausfrauen mittleren Alters aus dem Hamburger Umfeld, die sonst vielleicht E-Mails schreiben. Das war in einem Nachmittag die Einführung gegessen. Das wird seitdem von denen engagiert weiter eingepflegt. Da hat Plone den Anspruch, Vorreiter zu sein, was Benutzbarkeit und User-Interface betrifft.
Es hat ja auch so einen gewissen Stil. Das ist ja auch etwas, was man immer so bemerkt, wenn man auf so CMS trifft, egal wie konfigurierbar sie sind. Es gibt dann immer wieder so eine gewisse Sache. Mit Plonen assoziiere ich immer so unterstrichende Titel.
Viel Weiß.
Viel Weiß, da ist ja nichts gegen Einzuwenden, also auch gegen Unterstreichung nichts Einzuwenden. Aber das ist so etwas, was mir immer wieder auffällt bei solchen Plone-Sites. Und kleine Schrift. Ich finde die immer zu klein.
Ich mache die auch immer größer.
Da hat irgendwie zu wenig Leute eine Brille, glaube ich. Ich habe zwar auch keine, aber es ist trotzdem zu klein.
Ich meine, der Default-Look von Plone ist jetzt auch vier, fünf Jahre alt. Und ich glaube damals hatten die meisten Macs auch noch 72 DPI.
Sieht denn das immer noch so aus wie am Anfang?
Es gibt aktuell einen Skin, den nennt sich New Plone. Der ist von einem relativ neuen Mitglied der Community. Er ist ein sehr, sehr talentierter Web-Designer aus den Niederlanden, der Cornelis.
New Plone, so ganz new mit NU?
Na klar. Also wahlcomputer.ccde ist auch die Entwicklerversion von New Plone. Da sind noch ein paar Ecken und Kanten, aber ich konnte das alte einfach nicht mehr sehen. Und so wie Plone 3 und Zope 3 sozusagen die neue Generation ist, ist eben dieser New Plone-Skin auch das Gesicht dazu. Also für mich persönlich ist das alles eins. Also ich verwende eigentlich nur noch den neuen Skin. Und den alten, den klassischen Plone-Look mit den hellgrünen Kästchen überall herum, das ist vielleicht nicht besonders hübsch, aber es war ja auch darauf ausgelegt auf Bedienbarkeit. Und eine häufige Konstellation ist oder Konfiguration ist, dass die Redaktion über diesen Standard-Skin, der nur marginal verändert wird, vielleicht ein Logo ausgetauscht, halt den Inhalt einpflegt und das nach außen hin für den anonymen Besucher oder für den öffentlichen Besucher ein komplettes Skinning stattfindet. Das heißt, von außen sehen die meisten Plone-Sites, da kann man überhaupt nicht erkennen, dass es Plone ist. Außer, dass man wirklich in den Source-Code reinguckt und bestimmte Namenskonventionen...
Wie schwierig ist es, so eine neue Optik zu schaffen?
Es hat auch eine gewisse Lernkurve. Ein wichtiges Feature ist, dass man Basisänderungen auch einfach through the Web machen kann. Das heißt, ich kann einfach, indem ich mich im Redaktionsinterface rumklicke, Logo und Futter austausche, und diese ganzen Komponenten, aus denen der Bildschirm die fertige Seite besteht, die kann ich einfach so direkt mit einem Klick rein ändern und erledigen. Das ist through the Web. Das ist ganz wichtig. Und wenn ich darüber hinaus das noch weiter treiben will, dann muss ich halt ein sogenanntes Produkt schreiben, ein Plone-Produkt. Und da gibt es, ähnlich wie jetzt bei Ruby on Rails oder Django, gibt es entsprechende Skripte, Generatoren, die mir ein bisschen Boilerplate generieren. Bei uns heißt es dann Paster. Dann sage ich Create Plone Product oder Plone Theme. Dann gebe ich dem einen Namen und dann schmeißt er mir eine Verzeichnisstruktur auf die Platte, wo ich dann loslegen kann und dann direkt im Fallsystem einen CSS oder die Templates verändern kann.
Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, was alles hinzukommt. Wenn du gesagt hast, es hat mehr Benutzer, das hat Zope auch. Plone bringt jetzt überhaupt erst mal was Visuelles mit sich.
Es gibt dem überhaupt einen Look.
Templates gibt es in Zope noch gar nicht.
Doch, doch, aber halt nicht so viele out of the box. Die Standard Templates sind sehr spartanisch.
Das heißt, Zope hat schon ein Templatesystem?
Ja, ein Templating-System, klar.
Das auch Plone benutzt?
Was fügt dem Plone noch hinzu? Vor allem eine ganze Masse an Templates, die überhaupt da sind. Zum Beispiel verschiedene Default-Looks für eine Seite oder auch für ein Directory-Listing. Und diese Templates sind ja nicht nur das, was man an der Browser sieht. Zum Beispiel auch ein RSS-Feed, das ist ja letztendlich auch nur eine andere View auf einen Ordner. Das heißt, da gibt es ein extra Template, das dann halt ein RSS-Feed generisch für alle Site-Objekte zur Verfügung stellt. Oder eben eine iCal-Sicht auf einen Termin, solche Sachen. Da ist halt ganz viel Detailzeug, ganz viel Fleißarbeit, die da mit drinsteckt und die dann auch unter der Haube teilweise zu Werke ist.
Und, ok, dann beschreib doch noch mal so ein bisschen, was kann man jetzt mit Plonen konkret publizieren?
Genau, das wäre auch der nächste Punkt, weil was es auch mit sich bringt, ist halt eben nicht ein Satz von Basis-Content-Typen, eben eine Webseite darüber hinaus, dann natürlich noch Bilder, Dateien, Termine, also die Sachen, die dann zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt stattfinden. Es gibt dann auch einen Kalender-Portler. Das sind, glaube ich, auch so Standardsachen, die die anderen Content-Management-Systeme auch mit sich bringen. Dass ich dann halt, wenn ich Termine erstelle und die veröffentliche, dass die dann an dem speziellen Tag dann auch im Kalender erscheinen. Und an dem Tag wird dann dargestellt, ok, da findet was statt.
Gibt es dann für diese Termine auch gleich so ein Web-Kall-Feed, dass ich das in so einem Kalender-Programm abonnieren kann?
Ja, das ist allerdings nicht Autos of Box. Wir wollen natürlich auch versuchen, den Kern jetzt nicht zu überladen. Sonst machen wir wieder denselben Fehler und kramm so eine riesen Eier legende Wollmännig-Sau. Aber es gibt halt auch sehr viele, sehr brauchbare Zusatzprodukte, die dann zum Beispiel so etwas dann zur Verfügung stellen.
Das heißt, es gibt Module, die ich mir einfach dazu inszenieren kann?
Genau, bei uns heißen die dann einfach Produkte, aus historischen Gründen. Und was jetzt auch Sub 3 mit sich bringt, ist, dass es halt eine Möglichkeit gibt, so etwas noninvasiv zu machen. Das heißt, früher war das so, wenn man zum Beispiel nicht nur Bilder hochladen wollte, sondern es sollte auch eine Slideshow sein. Dann hat jemand es hergegangen, hat irgendwie das Image-Objekt abgeleitet und hat gesagt, ich, dieses Image-Objekt kann jetzt noch mehr. Das hat eine Transition und schlag mich tot. Und dann sind alle Bilder, die damit erstellt worden waren, dann eben nicht mehr Basis-Images, sondern spezielle Slideshow-Images. Und wenn ich das Produkt deinstalliert habe, dann konnte Zope mit dem Ding nichts mehr anfangen und dann hatte man irgendwie hier Datenmüll. Und durch die Zope-3-Komponenten-Architektur, die dahintersteckt, ist es so etwas, dass es für die Standard-Basis-Typen, also diese basalen Typen wie Datei und Bild, wird neues Verhalten hinzugefügt. Das ist sehr schwer zu vermitteln, aber der praktische Vorteil ist, ich kann mir so ein Produkt ausprobieren, laden mir 1000 Bilder hoch, dann gefällt es mir nicht, ich deinstalliere es und übrig bleiben jetzt ganz normale Bilder. Die haben jetzt zwar keinen fließenden Übergang mehr, aber es ist nach wie vor Standard-Bilder, JPEGs, PNGs, ohne irgendetwas.
Das heißt, man definiert einfach nur ein anderes Verhalten?
Man definiert anderes Verhalten, ohne dass man die eigentlichen Daten selber verändert. Und das kann man bei Bildern, mit Slideshows, das ist ein triviales Beispiel. Man kann natürlich das gleich auch mit MP3s machen. Also es gibt ein Projekt, das speziell für Multimedia ausgerichtet ist. Das ist das Plone for Artists Projekt, das eben diverse Module da zur Verfügung stellt. Und das Plone for Artists Audio ist so, wenn ich eine MP3-Datei hochlade, dann ist es erst mal nur, aus Sicht von Plone, erst mal nur ein Blob, also eine binäre Datei. Aber das Plone for Artists-Modul kann dann zum Beispiel die Metadaten, die in einem MP3 drin sind, auslesen, beim Hochladen und entsprechend diese Daten dann auch in der Datenbank importieren. Also Titel und Autor, Bitrate und Dauer und so etwas. Und kann dann zum Beispiel auch in die Seite entsprechenden Flash-Player.
Das ist eine Anlage, die Dauer festzustellen.
Wenn die eingetragen ist?
In den Metadaten steht das ja nicht drin.
Ich weiß aber, dass er die Dauer kann. Also dass er dann irgendwann...
Also das piekt er dann richtig rein. Das würde ich ja mal gerne ausrühren, ob das funktioniert. Ich habe schon so einige Systeme gesehen. Mit unterschiedlichen Qualitäten. Heißt das, dass man dann auch mal locker eben ein Podcast daraus machen kann?
Das ist die Idee dahinter, ja. Also zum Beispiel Plone for Artists, dieses Gesamtpaket, das hat dann auch eben gleich ein Podcast-Feed, der dann daraus erstellt wird. Hinter den Kulissen ist es nach wie vor immer nur ein Ordner, der halt Dateien enthält, die dann zufällig MP3s darstellen. Und dieses ganze Drumherum, dass ich einen Flash Player habe, um eine Preview zu hören, oder dass ich dann auf einmal noch ein iTunes-Feed dazu habe. Das ist alles zusätzliches Verhalten. Und wenn ich dieses Produkt wieder deinstalliere, dann bleibt einfach nur ein Ordner mit MP3s zurück. Und ich könnte zum Beispiel ein anderes Produkt ersetzen, das verspricht, besser zu machen. Und das war früher eben nicht so, man hat so etwas installiert, und dann hat man da so einen speziellen Datentypen, die irgendwie abgeleitet wurden. Und da wurden die Daten mit dem Code verheiratet. Und was Zope mitbringt, ist eben einen sauberen Mechanismus, das zu trennen. Und Plone selbst bedient sich jetzt zunehmend dieser Mechanismen. Mit jeder weiteren Revision wird da mehr ersetzt. Und die Zusatzprodukte natürlich erst recht. Also für die Third-Party-Autoren ist es natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen, weil sie können richtig mitmischen, in den Prozess mit eingreifen, ohne dass sie praktisch Plone forken müssen. Und für die User ist es gut, sie können Sachen ausprobieren, ohne sich festzulegen.
Du meinst jetzt Programmierer, die dem Projekt was hinzufügen wollen, ohne jetzt Teil der Kern-Community zu sein?
Genau. Oder vielleicht auch, weil ich hier auch Produkte schreibe, die proprietär sind, weil das für meine Kunden ist. Und die gewisse Funktionalitäten einfach keinen Sinn machen. Und das realisiere ich dann natürlich auch als Produkt. Und wenn dann eine neue Version von Plone rauskommt, dann ist es schwer, dem Kunden zu vermitteln, dass er jetzt praktisch auch eine neue Version von seinem Produkt nochmal einen Auftrag geben muss, weil der Code halt mit dieser speziellen Version verheiratet ist.
Kann ja immer passieren, aber jetzt passiert das weniger.
Es ist weniger häufig und weniger schlimm.
Ich würde ganz gerne nochmal bei diesen Features bleiben. Interessiert mich natürlich jetzt gerade, weil ich im Vorfeld dieses, als wir hier den Termin noch geplant haben, auch dieses Plone4Artist schon mal angesprochen, damit kann man auch Chaos Radio machen. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, ob man das wirklich kann, weil da fallen mir natürlich gleich 1000 Sachen ein, die ich da irgendwie reingebaut habe. Chaos Radio CTE ist ja so eine statische Webseite. Ich mache ja seit Jahren irgendwie nur XSLT. Das hat schon etwas manisches, aber mir haben alle anderen dynamischen Subsysteme halt immer irgendwie nicht gefallen. Die brachten mir dann immer zu viel Fußabdruck mit rein, sei es die Optik oder wie die URL aufgebaut ist. Ich brauche einfach diese Freiheit.
Sehr interessant, man wird zu viel gezwungen.
Genau, das will man dann nicht. Und irgendwann passt es dann auch mal ganz konkret nicht mehr. Das ist glaube ich auch das, was Leute grundsätzlich von CMSen irgendwie abhält. Zurecht. Dass sie einfach zu viel auferlegt. Und gerade jetzt bei Chaos Radio habe ich es mit Datenformaten zu tun, wo ich immer wieder gemerkt habe, es ist extrem wichtig, dass ich auch wirklich die Fine-Grain-Control habe. Also nur so etwas wie ein iCalendar-Feed. Also was man da alles irgendwie falsch machen kann, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Mir hat es dann sehr geholfen, doch einfach mal ein bisschen in den Standard reinzuschauen, mal zu gucken, wie das eigentlich wirklich ist, um dann festzustellen, dass irgendwie 90% aller Tools da draußen einfach alles falsch machen. Es ist zum Heulen. Aber deswegen interessiert mich jetzt vor allem, wie diese Erweiterbarkeit von Plonen ist. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist das ja auch eins der Hauptfeatures des Systems.
Ja, des neuen, des guten Soaps, des guten Plonen.
Wir reden nur über das gute Soap.
Wir haben ja aus den Fehlern gelernt. Es hat auch wirklich eben konkrete Vorteile. Es gibt Wiki-Behaviour, es gibt Wiki-Markup, das man einschalten kann. Dann wird der Text, gewisse Links werden dann entsprechend auch als Links interpretiert und gerendert. Damit habe ich persönlich aber noch keine großen Erfahrungen gesammelt. Das ist a Plone 3 mit dabei.
Aber theoretisch kann es ein Wiki sein?
Es kann ein Wiki sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein gutes Wiki sein kann.
Hat das Camel Case?
Ich glaube, eins davon...
Wenn es Camel Case hat, ist es kein gutes Wiki.
Ich muss mir... Der Wit, der das geschrieben hat, der hat eben so eine... Die haben sich dann letztendlich auf eine, ich glaube, dreifach runde Klammern, also dreimal runde Klammer auf, Link schreiben dreimal runde Klammer zu, weil das auf allen Tastaturen gut zu erreichen ist, im Gegensatz zu einer geschweiften oder einer eckigen, wo viele Deutsche oder Französische... Shift 9, Shift 8. Frag mal einen französischen Durchschnitts-User, wie man eine geschweifte Klammer herstellt. Das weiß der Deutsche gar nicht. Man braucht ja eckige Klammern. Das wissen die auch. Alt, Shift, Alt, 5 oder so einen Kragen. Das ist für die meisten... Eine runde Klammer kann jeder. Jeder, der tippen kann, kann eine runde. Das war eine Design-Entscheidung, das habe ich mitbekommen am Rande. Das ist aber auch konfigurierbar. Ich weiß nicht, zu welchem Grad.
Ich bin ja nicht so der Wikimensch. Ich bin ja der Wikimensch. Ich glaube ja, dass Media-Wiki die meisten Sachen richtig macht. Nicht alles, aber das mit den eckigen Klammern und so weiter. Ohne Camel-Case, das haben sie schon ganz richtig bekommen. Aber ich will jetzt nicht so sehr auf Wikis rumreiten. Was mich noch interessiert ist, wie funktioniert das mit Mehrsprachigkeit?
Das ist ja auch ein heißes Eisen. Genau. Eins, das sich Plone ganz groß auf die Fahne geschrieben hat, das war auch etwas, das in der Zweierversion von Plone schon sehr gut funktioniert hat. Mit einem Zusatztool, das dann schon fast eigentlich zum Kern gehört hat, das nennt sich Lingua-Plone, wo man auch Through the Web übersetzen konnte. Also man konnte einfach eine Default-Sprache einstellen. Jedes Objekt hat sowieso einen Sprachflag. Das bringt allein schon der Doubling Core mit sich. Da ist natürlich auch mit codiert, wer in welcher Sprache dieses Ding ist oder ob es überhaupt in einer speziellen Sprache drin ist. Und das kann ich dann einfach übersetzen. Ich kriege dann irgendwie translate into oder übersetzen nach, je nachdem, welche Sprache ich schon mal eingestellt habe. Und das System weiß, dass diese neue Seite, die erstellt wurde, ist eine Übersetzung von einer bestehenden Seite. Und wenn ich dann praktisch mit meinem Browser irgendwie schon die Standardsprache Deutsch eingestellt habe und du gehst auf eine Plone-Site, dann ist es out of the box auch so, dass du dann das deutsche User-Interface vorgesetzt bekommst. Einfach über die Browser-Negotiation. Und das sind ganz viele brauchbare Features, die da sich angesammelt haben über die Zeit. Das war auch gleichzeitig ein gutes Beispiel für wie Open Source-Sponsoring passieren kann. Der Hauptauslöser, dass dieses Modul geschrieben wurde, das ist Oxfam, diese wohltätige Einrichtung weltweit. Genau was weiß ich leider auch nicht. Aber deren Website ist in Plone geschrieben. Die haben 15 Stück davon in verschiedenen Sprachen. Die haben die Entwicklung dieses Produktes gesponsert. Das ist unter der GPL. Das meiste von Plone ist unter der GPL, nicht unter der ZPL. Aus historischen Gründen. Daraus entstand, da wurden ein paar 10.000 Dollar draufgeschüttet und Gehirnschmalz draufgeworfen. Das steht jetzt der Plone-Community zur Verfügung. Das hat den Schritt nach drei noch nicht ganz vollzogen. Da hakt es noch ein bisschen am Ecken und Enden. Das muss noch ein bisschen poliert werden.
Wie lange wird denn dieser Schritt nach drei noch dauern?
Der eine Schritt ist auf Zope bezogen. Das heißt, wann kann man praktisch Zope 2 komplett rausschmeißen aus Plone und es wird trotzdem noch laufen mit allen Features. Sprich, alle Tests werden laufen. Das kann noch Jahre dauern. Es wird den Enduser auch nicht so interessant. Den Plone-User selber interessiert das alles gar nicht. Der weiß gar nicht den Unterschied zwischen, der weiß nicht mehr, was Zope ist. Er muss es auch nicht wissen. Das ist ja auch das Schöne daran, dass eben Leute befähigt werden, Content ins Netz zu stellen und den so zu bearbeiten, dass es eigentlich sogar Spaß macht. Das ist eher das Hauptanliegen. Plone selber ist überhaupt nicht technisch fokussiert. Man könnte theoretisch Plone auch in Ruby on Rails oder Gott bewahre in PHP nachprogrammieren. Das würde die Community, das User-Interface und auch die Design-Entscheidungen, die dahinterstecken, das würde es eher ausmachen.
Du sagst ja auch schon die ganze Zeit, wir, jetzt wurde gerade die Community erwähnt. Vielleicht kannst du ja ein bisschen mal was nochmal sagen, was dein eigener Beitrag ist und wie diese Community so funktioniert.
Genau, für mich war das dann eben auch persönlich am eigenen Leib zu spüren, dass das die Community ein großer Faktor ausmacht. Also für mich ist Plone halt eben auch der erste wirkliche Kontakt zur Open-Source-Community oder überhaupt den ersten echten Kontakt mit Open-Source. Also jetzt nicht einfach nur als Nutznieser, sondern auch jemand, der sich jetzt als Mitglied einer Community bezeichnet. Das war dann gleich 2005, als ich zum ersten Mal auf der, es gibt jährlich eine Konferenz, die wird auch jedes Jahr größer. Die fand damals in Wien statt. Das ist die Plone-Conference, ganz schnödel. Die letzte war jetzt diesen Sommer in Neapel. Davor in Seattle und die beiden Male davor in Wien. Die Plone-Community ist auch sehr reisefreudig. Es finden immer wieder Sprints statt. Das sind Sessions, wo Leute zusammenkommen, um an einem bestimmten Modul zu arbeiten. Da vergeht eigentlich kaum ein Monat, dass da nicht irgendwo in der Welt sich 10, 20, 30 Plonistas versammeln und für ein paar Tage zu Werke gehen. Dort war mein erster Kontakt mit den Leuten, die dahinterstecken. Wenn du das erste Mal ein Gesicht siehst, das du vorher nur aus dem ERC kennst oder von der Mailing-Liste, das war für mich schon ein recht einschneidendes Erlebnis, weil ich vorher immer nur mit Leuten zu tun im Chaos-Umfeld hatte, wo ich die Leute zuerst persönlich kennengelernt habe und dann ihre schreckliche Fratze auf der Mailing-Liste. Das hat mich dann tatsächlich gesehen, das sind eben nicht nur Nerds, sondern die Plone-Community umfasst tatsächlich auch ein viel breiteres Spektrum an Leuten. Das ist zu meinen, es ist halt sehr verbreitet in akademischen Bereichen, also das sind dann irgendwelche universitären Webmaster, zum Beispiel mit dabei oder auch Wissenschaftler, die dann halt ein Ontologieprodukt schreiben und das dann in Plonen implementieren. Eben auch viele Kreativen. Und das macht sich schon irgendwie bemerkbar. Und die Community ist auch sehr offen. Also man muss nicht Nerd sein, um irgendwie, es ist eine Meritokratie wie alle anderen guten Open-Source-Communities auch, aber sie ist halt keine Technokratie. Man bekommt, sie ist sehr offen. Ich hab mich da dann auch relativ schnell zu Hause gefühlt, obwohl ich damals noch keine Zeile Python schreiben konnte. Und darüber bin ich sozusagen so langsam eingesickert. Technisch gesehen habe ich das Contributor Agreement unterschrieben und habe dadurch Schreibzugriff auf das Subversion Repository von Zope und Plone. Aber das ist eigentlich nur der technische Aspekt. Ein paar Patches von mir sind in der aktuellen Version drin, das ist aber nicht besonders viel, auf aus zeitlichen Gründen. Die andere Art, wie ich mich jetzt einbringe zurzeit, ist, es gibt etwas, das nennt sich das Framework Team. Das ist sozusagen die Jury, durch die alle Features passieren müssen, an die alle Features vorbei müssen, die in die nächste Version rein sollen. Das heißt, das wird bei uns auch sehr groß geschrieben, dass es da nicht einfach so einen Wildwuchs an Features gibt, sondern dass das halt im Vorfeld diskutiert wird. Da gibt es die sogenannten PLIPs, die Plone Improvement Proposals, wo man eine Idee vorstellt. Ja, das ist auch sehr bürokratisch, aber es ist...
Na ja, manchmal ist Bürokratie nicht schlecht.
Ja, es ist die Mischung zwischen dem benevolent dictator, der alleine alles entscheidet, und dem Wildwuchs, wo zu viele Köche den Brei verderben. Das ist natürlich auch ein interessantes soziales Experiment, weil dieser Mechanismus, der ist ja noch im Entstehen. Das Framework-Team hat sich... Das sind fünf Mitglieder. Dann wird über jedes Feature abgestimmt, ob wir das überhaupt so wollen. Wenn das dann das Okay bekommen hat, dann wird nochmal die Implementierung geordetet. Man schaut sich den Code an, diskutiert es auf der Liste usw. Dieses Jahr übrigens auch. Drei von den fünf Mitgliedern sind aus Berlin. Das hat sich so ergeben. Drei von fünf Mitgliedern des Plon-Framework-Teams, das jetzt über die Version 3.1 entscheidet, dass die jetzt aus Berlin sind. Die hätten wir ja auch noch einladen können.
Und gibt es dann hier in Berlin auch einen Stammtisch? Ich wusste, dass es Zope-Entwickler gibt hier in Berlin.
Ich glaube, es hat eher persönliche Gründe. Andy, der andere ist Zeitler. Der andere ist auch ein sehr aktiver Core-Entwickler. Der hat auch einige der neuen Features komplett durchgeboxt und gemacht. Der ist da viel aktiver. Das andere ist der Raphael Ritz von Plone. Wobei der auch mittlerweile nahenlos bei Zope zugesteht. Da bleiben wir eher unter uns. Es gibt so ein paar Stammtische, aber wir sind wahrscheinlich zu beschäftigt. Aber es ist definitiv keine Arroganz.
Für meinen Geschmack habe ich jetzt noch zu wenig Werbung gehört für die Features von Plone. Da kannst du jetzt gerne noch mal ein bisschen nachlegen. Was mir so aus dem Stand einfällt, ist, dass Plone das erste System war, was so ein Visivic-JavaScript-Editor-Support betritt.
Für viele Leute war Plone der Visivic-Editor. Das war das Core-Feature. Das war 2002, wenn ich das den Leuten gezeigt habe. Das war immer der Aufhänger. Dass es einfach ein JavaScript-basiertes Editing-Tool gibt, das so grob Visivic kann, wie man das mittlerweile fast alle unterstreichen und verlinken und Überschriften. Dass man das gleich live sieht. Das war damals ein Zeitlang ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Jetzt natürlich nicht mehr. Aber in dieselbe Kerbe hauen auch die anderen Features. Plone hat in der 3. Version auch ein sehr ausgereiftes AJAX-Framework. Das hat ein bisschen länger gedauert. Da waren wir nicht die ersten. Das könnte jetzt zu technisch werden. Die meisten AJAX-Features sind geschrieben in einer Sprache, also nicht in Java Script, sondern in KSS. Das ist syntaktisch CSS. Da kann ich bestimmte Actions, bestimmte Notes zuordnen. Zum Beispiel den ersten Paragrafen mit der Klasse Heading. Der kann ich dann eine Aktion zuordnen. Diese Aktion muss nicht kleinseitig sein, sondern kann auch serverseitig sein. Zum Beispiel eine Validierung. Das KSS-Framework übernimmt dann transparent einfach das Übertragen der Daten hin und her. Standardmäßig mit JSON. Aber ich als Entwickler schreibe einfach drei Zeilen KSS und verknüpfe damit ein beliebiges Element meiner Seite mit einer serverseitigen Aktion. Da habe ich zum Beispiel jetzt letztens einen Stundenplan erstellt. Das ist eine Tabelle, irgendwie 7 x 24. Durch Klick auf eine beliebige Tabelle, das Event habe ich mit zwei Zeilen KSS praktisch definiert, dann soll diese Stunde aktiv werden, so ein Stundenplan. Dann soll diese Stunde besetzt werden. Das ist auch nur eine ganz kleine Routine. Und das war komplett ohne eine Zeile JavaScript zu schreiben, habe ich dann praktisch interaktiv. Ich klicke auf dem Stundenplan rum.
Das heißt, aus diesem KSS wird dann der entsprechende JavaScript-Code generiert?
Nein, KSS ist praktisch, es gibt einen kleinseitigen sozusagen KSS-Interpreter. Der ist ein JavaScript geschrieben. Du kannst das KSS wieder wie Bytecode vorstellen. Das ist aber jetzt der technische Background. Wenn wir jetzt zu den Features wieder zurückkommen, hat das dafür gesorgt, dass nachdem das erstmal fertig war, kam eine ganze Welle von Ajax-Features halt reingespült, weil die jetzt auf einmal mit ein paar Zeilen zu realisieren waren. Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich fast überall Inline-Editing.
Das kann man ruhig nochmal kurz vertiefen. Ich gucke jetzt gerade noch drüber, das ist ja ziemlich cool. Das heißt, man hat jetzt nicht so, wie das jetzt woanders ist, mit dem Prototype-Framework und den ganzen JavaScript-Features, sondern man hat einfach gesagt, okay, wir haben eher eine generische, wie nenne ich das jetzt mal, Webseiten-Elemente-Modifikationssprache geschaffen.
Auf Basis von CSS, das hat sich bewährt mit den Selektoren.
Richtig, was ja sozusagen auch nichts anderes macht, als diese Webseiten-Elemente zu beschreiben für die Formatierung. Und letztendlich sind ja auch diese ganzen Ajax-Geschichten mit, Button wird irgendwie rot, ist ja auch eigentlich nichts anderes. Ah, dann läuft einfach nur so eine kleine Runtime-Engine im Web-Browser, die dieses KSS zur Laufzeit einfach entgegennimmt.
Genau.
Und dann umsetzt.
Pfiffig.
Das ist sehr pfiffig. Dieses KSS wurde auch so, das ist nicht, dass Plone und Zope sozusagen die ersten Nutzen dieser davon. Das ist aber überhaupt nicht Zope, Python oder Plone spezifisch.
Das könnte sich vor allem noch durchsetzen.
Mittlerweile gibt es eine Implementierung für Django. Serverseitig muss man sich eigentlich nur auf ein paar bestimmte JSON-Anfragen reagieren. Bis jetzt hat es noch keiner gemacht, aber es wäre technisch kein größeres Problem, sowas dann auch serverseitig in PHP oder Java zu implementieren.
Okay, also was für User Interface-Elemente sind jetzt daraus geboren worden?
Das eine ist zum Beispiel das Inline-Editing. Das heißt, wenn ich Schreibrechte habe auf einer Seite, dann kann ich auf die meisten Elemente eines Objektes einfach einmal klicken. Und dann wird aus dem Titel halt ein Edit-Feld. Dann kann ich den Titel editieren, drück Return. Inplace. Ja, wir nennen das Inline-Editing.
Kann man damit auch die Mehrsprachigkeit seiner Webseite irgendwie gleich machen?
Ich glaube, Nupelone hat da in der Ansicht, müssen wir ausprobieren, wie weit die da sind. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel eben auch so eine Zwei-Spalten-Ansicht. Bei links habe ich den Originaltext in Deutsch, und rechts kann ich dann einfach den Englischen reinschreiben und dann absprechen. Also sowas ist in der Mache, ich weiß nicht, wie ausgeweicht das ist. Aber allein schon bei den jungen Mädels vom Wahlcomputer war das auch einfach der Bringer. Ich habe das denen einmal gezeigt, du klickst in den Bodytext rein, dann rendert er dir außenrum die WYSIWYG-Elemente und du kannst direkt los tippen und auf Speichern gehen und dann wird der geänderte Text an den Server geschickt. Und du musst da die Seite nicht lösen.
Also man kriegt nicht so ein riesiges Textform, und dann muss man irgendwie save sagen.
Da macht es manchmal Sinn, so einen riesigen Aufwand für Ajax zu betreiben, weil du sparst in der Praxis halt vielleicht nur ein paar Sekunden. Aber wenn du halt viele Änderungen machen willst, dann kommst du wirklich auf jede Sekunde an. Also wenn du dann 10 Änderungen machst, und hast dann eben nur eine halbe Minute gebraucht statt zwei Minuten, das macht dann tatsächlich einen Unterschied.
Das macht ja auch die Programmierung einfacher, weil man ja irgendwie viel weniger Input hat und der User sehr viel direkter das ansteuern kann, was man letztendlich haben will. Weitere Beispiele außer jetzt so In-Place-Editing?
Auch In-Place Workflow Transitions. Also ich kann das Ding auf Publish, also Publishen zum Beispiel, und dann wird nicht die ganze Seite neu gerendert, sondern es wird einfach nur das Widget, das eben den Workflow-Zustand anzeigt. Also standardmäßig geht es dann halt von rot auf grün.
Ich glaube, da musst du noch mal generell was zu sagen. Das sieht sich nämlich noch so ein bisschen als Selbstverständlichkeit an. Das ist ja was Inherentes in Plone. Bevor ich etwas veröffentliche, ist es erstmal ein Draft oder wie?
Genau, das setzt natürlich auf die, wir haben vorhin schon erwähnt, den Permissions an und ist sozusagen eine Convenience. Das sind wirklich vorgefertigte Permission-Sets, wo ich sagen kann, der Zustand Draft heißt, Anonymous darf nicht sehen und darf natürlich auch nicht schreiben, aber Manager darf lesen und schreiben und Member darf nur lesen. Das heißt, man könnte dann sagen, manche Mitglieder können Draft-Elemente zwar sehen, aber noch nicht verändern. Und der Manager darf dann zum Beispiel die auch noch verändern. Und wenn sie dann gepublished sind, dann habe ich ein anderes Set an Rechten. Dann darf nämlich auch Anonymous die Sache sehen, aber immer noch nicht schreiben. Und Plone liefert eben auch mittlerweile out of the box verschiedene Workflows. Also es gibt so einen Simple Workflow, wo man davon ausgeht, ja, Published, Non-Published, mit mehr muss ich meine User nicht verwirren. Dann gibt es ja auch so etwas wie Intranet. Also du willst es dann vielleicht nur intern publishen, aber der User da draußen darf es trotzdem nicht sehen. Aber der Abteilungsleiter, der andere Mitarbeiter, da darf es schon sehen, aber der öffentliche User nicht. Das ist dann so ein etwas komplexerer Workflow out of the box. Und dann sowas wie wir jetzt für die Wahlcomputer, ist dann so ein Standard-Workflow. Man kann dann zum Beispiel auch manche Leute haben nur die Rechte zu schreiben, aber noch nicht zu veröffentlichen. Das heißt, es gibt eine automatische Review-Liste. Das heißt, wenn ich die Review-Rechte habe und jemand hat einen Text eingereicht und möchte, dass der veröffentlicht wird, dann habe ich da automatisch so eine Benachrichtigung und sehe, neue Texte gucke ich durch, kann ich dann zurückweisen oder veröffentlichen. Das ist dann zum Beispiel sehr bürokratisch. Für manche ist es natürlich wichtig, dass nicht jeder sofort was veröffentlichen darf. Vielleicht auch aus rechtlichen Gründen, weil die sich dann irgendwie vor, muss es noch die Rechtsabteilung irgendwie angucken. Damals für die Datenschleuder war das natürlich einfach nur...
Es ist ja nicht alles Wikipedia auf diesem Planeten. Das muss man ja auch sehen. Und manchmal ist es ja auch ganz sinnvoll, wenn man mal irgendwas geschrieben hat und jemand anderes schaut nochmal drüber, bevor man es rausgibt.
Für einen Entwickler ist es einfach, mit dieser App eigene Workflows zu implementieren. Also jetzt habe ich gerade irgendwas mit einer Auktion. Da ist halt so ein eingestellter Gegenstand, der ist halt noch nicht aktiv, aber auch noch nicht verkauft. Und irgendwann ist er halt verkauft. Und das kann ich mit diesem Workflow dann ganz einfach abbilden. Und ich muss nur diesen Workflow konfigurieren. Und die Widgets nehme ich, dass sich dann so ein Auto auf Publish stellen kann oder auf verkauft. Das geht dann eben auch mit Ajax inline direkt, weil ich habe mir einfach nur einen anderen Workflow dafür gefilmt.
Einer der Gründe, warum ich Wikis immer für eine tolle Idee gehalten habe und auch immer noch halte, ist, dass sie so Out of the Box Versionen mit sich bringen. Und vor allem auch, dass man eben schnell sehen kann, wer hat wo, wann was geändert. Und dann eben auch diese einzelnen Schritte gegebenenfalls, wenn ich die Rechte habe, zurücknehmen kann.
Das ist etwas, was Plone 3 jetzt auch endlich mitbringt. Das hat auch länger gedauert als bei den anderen, so ähnlich wie mit dem KSS. Aber ich habe auch den Eindruck, obwohl ich natürlich hochgradig befangen bin, dass es dir diese Warterei gelohnt hat.
Sei befangen. Wir kommen noch andere Podcasts mit anderen Content-Managementsystemen. Die werden dir sowieso widersprechen.
Sehr gut, darauf freue ich mich schon. Also standardmäßig sind die Default-Content-Typen eben auch versioniert. Es ist natürlich schwierig bei so komplexeren Content-Typen, wie wenn ich da XHTML mit einem WixiWik-Editor mache, die Änderungen überhaupt zu sehen. Oder wenn ich stark formularlastige Daten habe, also die Content-Typen, die wirklich sehr viele extra Felder habe. Aber es gibt da schon eine sehr vernünftige Implementierung, die an diese Diff-Darstellung in den Wikis angelehnt ist.
Diese Visualisierung mit Diff ist ja noch mal eine andere Geschichte. Aber überhaupt erst mal sehen zu können, was für Änderungen sind denn jetzt hier vorgenommen worden in der letzten, was weiß ich, und das dann vielleicht auch noch als RSS-Feed rauszuspucken. Ist das machbar?
Das ist bestimmt machbar. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob es out of the box dabei ist. Aber das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel etwas, das würde ich zur Not halt ganz spröde...
Als Verbesserungsvorschlag notieren.
Ja, das kann ich.
Und ins Komitee einreichen.
Für Clone 32.
Find ich wichtig. Gerade bei so Projekten, was weiß ich jetzt hier, so Wahlcomputer und so weiter, da hat man nicht immer die Zeit, dem zu folgen. Man weiß aber, zehn Leute sind da irgendwie am Acker, am Machen, am Tun. Und manchmal reicht es halt einfach nur, um so ein RSS-Feed zu beobachten. Wenn ich das jetzt aber machen könnte, mit irgendwie alle Änderungen, die ich sehen darf, bitte als RSS, dann habe ich das irgendwie da.
Auch das Problem haben wir generisch gelöst. Es gibt nämlich ein allgemeines Modul, das nennt sich Content Rules. Und es gibt so verschiedene Events. Also das ist dann wieder eine Untermenge von diesen hunderten oder Dutzenden von Events, die das Zope zur Verfügung stellt. Und da gibt es eine sozusagen Human Readable Version, also zum Beispiel verändern, speichern, erstellen, löschen, so das sind so basale Elemente. Und für diese Events kann ich eben auch eigene Aktionen dann definieren. Das ist so ein bisschen wie eine ganz kleine Version von dem Automator unter Mac OS X, wo ich mir halt sozusagen zusammenklicken kann so eine Eventkette. Und als Aktion gibt es unter anderem eben auch E-Mail-Benachrichtigungen. Das heißt, ich könnte so etwas, auch wenn es das jetzt nicht out of the box gibt, könnte ich das Through the Web als User, nicht als Programmierer, mir zusammenklicken, dass jedes Mal, wenn ein bestimmtes Dokument verändert wird, dass ich dann wenigstens eine E-Mail kriege, dass ich weiß, es wurde verändert. Das würde zum Beispiel schon mal gehen.
Das weiß ich jetzt noch nicht, aber du wirst natürlich gleich wieder nach Hause gekommen, bis nach unserem Gespräch nachschauen.
Ich weiß, es gibt auch einen Ansatz, wir Plonistas wollen alles immer schön generisch lösen und warten auch lieber ein bisschen länger. Es gibt auch recht fortgeschrittene Arbeit an einem generischen RSS-System, das dann praktisch zu allen möglichen Events und Contenttypen generisch Feeds zur Verfügung stellt, die ich dann als Entwickler natürlich auch noch overriden und customisieren kann, um zum Beispiel einen iTunes-Feed in einer speziellen Version zu erstellen. Das gibt es zum Beispiel noch nicht, aber das ist zum Beispiel auch definitiv gewollt und ist halt in der Pipeline.
Es gibt noch so etwas wie einen Presentation-Modus, kann man dann auch gleich so Slideshows abfeuern?
Man kann das optional einschalten für Content, wo das Sinn macht. Der macht aus dem XHTML, aus dem Body und dem Text, macht einfach ein S5 draus. S5, Eric Meyers geniales CSS und JavaScript-basiertes Powerpoint for the Web.
Da habe ich noch nichts von gehört.
S5 von Eric Meyers, das ist großartig.
Eric Meyers, dieser CSS-Guru.
Genau, und der hat das einfach mal gemacht. Ich muss mal ein XHTML auszeichnen mit Überschrift, H1, H2, H3, Bullet Lists und das in Diffs packen. Mehr muss ich nicht machen. Dann wird darauf diese CSS und JavaScript losgelassen. Das lässt mich dann von einem Diff zum nächsten weiterblättern. Das wird dann dynamisch mit JavaScript gemacht. Wenn es mehr als fünf Bullet Points sind, macht das JavaScript die Schrift kleiner, damit es noch grob einpasst. Ich kann dann vor- und zurückblättern und so weiter. Ich vergebe bestimmte Klassen und kann dann über die Klassenwahl bei dem List-Item dafür sorgen, dass zum Beispiel Item für Item eingeblendet wird.
Einfache Sachen wie die Funktionalität eines Web-Blocks ist ja eigentlich von Anfang an schon mit drin gewesen, oder?
Es gibt diesen Content-Typ News-Item, der hat ein Datum, nämlich für den er gilt. Dem kann ich auch noch ein Bild und eine Caption hinzufügen. Das ist halt relativ starr. Und natürlich auch ein Body-Text. Da kann man sich dann auch austoben. Es gibt auch einen RSS-Feed, der alle News-Items in chronologischer Reihenfolge zur Verfügung stellt. Das heißt, man kann aus der Box eigentlich ein Basic-Blogging-System und ein ganz einfaches Blog hat man dann eigentlich schon mit am Start. Und es gibt diverse Produkte. Das ist einer der beliebtesten Produktthemen in der Welt. Es gibt also diverse Blogprodukte, die das dann noch ein bisschen aufpeppen. Die meisten davon kranken an dem, was wir vorhin erwähnt haben, dass die halt dann spezielle Content üben. Also irgendwie Simple-Blog-Entry oder Blog-Entry und so weiter. Das heißt, wenn ich das Produkt deinstalliere, dann geht mein ganzer Content flöten.
Das musst du dann auch erstmal wieder auf Zope 3 verflöten.
Exakt, und da sind wir auch dabei. Ich habe eins dieser Produkte selber auch. Da habe ich sozusagen mein I was scratching my own itch. Das ist Quills. Das ist sozusagen das ausgereifteste und reichhaltigste Blogprodukt. Damit läuft auch mein eigenes Blog. Und da sind wir auch dabei, das umzuschreiben, dass wir dann einfach Standard-News-Items mit zusätzlichem Verhalten ausstatten. Also zum Beispiel, dass es ein Archiv-View gibt. Weil die haben ja schon ein Datum. Und ich kann dann einfach auch zum Beispiel eine Archiv-Hierarchie dann zur Verfügung stellen, die dann praktisch on the fly, halt über die URL 2007 slash 10 löst dann halt eine Anfrage nach allen News-Items aus, die in diesem Bereich stattfinden und werden dann angezeigt. Dazu muss ich nicht extra noch ein eigenes Weblog-Archiv-Produkt schreiben, das dann eigenen Content-Typen darstellt und so weiter. Das ist ja technisch, aber unterm Strich heißt es einfach auch, ich kann dann halt, wird dann relativ bald, ein paar Monate wird es schon noch dauern, dann einfach mein out of the box Blog-Verhalten von einer Plone-Instanz einfach aufbohren, ohne dass ich die Daten selber dazu verändere oder anfassen muss.
So, jetzt sollten wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen die Sachen zusammenfassen. Was mich nochmal interessieren würde ist, für wen ist Plone und für wen ist Plone nicht?
Also das ist eine wichtige Frage. Und wie gesagt, dieses Hammer-Nagel-Problem sollte nicht einfach, nur weil man jetzt, also dem, mit dem bin ich selber auch am Anfang meiner Begeisterung verfallen, so alles, du willst es ins Web stellen, das machen wir mit Plone. Plone ist häufig auch einfach viel zu groß. Also es ist ein Schwergewicht, auch was Ressourcen betrifft. Und für den Benutzer ist es immer sehr einfach. Aber der Benutzer ist auch nur ein Teil der Gleichung. Irgendjemand muss das Ding ja auch aufsetzen, administrieren und warten und so weiter. Das ist für die meisten, wenn ich jetzt in einem Verein bin und habe jemand, der im Feierabend halt so etwas pflegen will, dann kann das durchaus sein, dass es besser ist, wenn er was Kleineres nimmt. So ähnlich wie Linux, vielleicht für die Schwiegermutter nicht unbedingt das Beste ist. Aber wenn ich eh ein Setup habe, wo es Admins gibt und die einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass die Updates aufgespielt werden, dann kann auch ein normaler Büroarbeiter oder Münchner Stadtverwaltungsbeamter auch prima mit Linux leben. Genau, wir wollen ja auch von irgendwas leben.
Ich denke, du bist kein Admin mehr.
Aber auf jeden Fall Zope und Plone-Anwender. Das heißt, ich erlebe ja auch davon, dass nicht alle das können, was ich kann und das dann für die einrichte und dann die im Alltag sich nicht damit rumschlagen müssen, dass wir auch ein bewährtes Implemen sind.
Wo fängt jetzt die Zielgruppe an? Also welcher Art von Organisation oder Projekt würdest du sagen, wenn du da die notwendigen administrativen Voraussetzungen schaffen kannst oder finanzieren kannst, dann ist das jetzt etwas, was dir an einer anderen Stelle so viel Arbeit abnimmt, dass sich das lohnt?
Eigentlich schwer zu sagen. Vielleicht noch ein anderes Beispiel, wo man auf jeden Fall sagen kann, das macht Sinn, ist Intranet-Anwendungen. Weil ich kann Plone einfach runterladen, installieren und es läuft. Das läuft dann halt auf Port 8080 und wenn ich nicht weiß, was ein Webserver ist, dann müssen halt meine User alle Port 8080 eingeben, ohne fancy Rewriting. Aber ich kann das einfach hier auf dem Rechner installieren. Es gibt schönes Kontrollfeld, Starten. Es gibt es für Windows, für Macintosh und für Linux. Als Standalone-Applikation. Das kannst du halt auf einem Linux-Server in der Ecke stehen hast, kannst du das da installieren und das läuft da. Das kriegt jeder hin. Und in dem Intranet-Bereich ist es ja vielleicht auch jetzt nicht so wichtig, dass du da noch irgendwie großartig was drumherum schreibst und Deployment und Caching und so, das spielt ja da alles keine Rolle. Das ist durchaus auch ein Szenario, wo Leute denken, das haben sie früher mit FileMaker gemacht, weil sie da alles selber machen können, aber irgendwie ist es zu teuer. Und das ist auch noch so eine Nische, wo man sagt, ich möchte strukturiert gemeinsam im Netzwerk Daten bearbeiten. Und da gibt es auch einen riesen Bedarf. Also wenn du auf Google FileMaker sucks eingibst, dann landest du seit drei Jahren als erster Hit auf einen Eintrag von mir, wo ich genau darüber über FileMaker abrahnte, weil ich da bei einem Kunden das Ding durch eine Plone-Instance ersetzt habe. Ich will nicht Plone jetzt als FileMaker-Ersatz grundsätzlich propagieren, aber es gibt einen großen Anwendungsbereich, wo die Leute nicht so viel Datenbank brauchen und so viel Struktur, sondern einfach strukturiert die Daten ablegen wollen und gemeinsam darauf zugreifen. Dafür brauchst du nicht mal einen richtig großen Admin dazu, du musst eigentlich nur den Installer ausführen können. Das ist der praktische Anwendungsbereich, den es gibt.
Das würde ich noch mal nachhaken. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Dieser Bereich Desktop-Database ist ja nach wie vor vollständig vernachlässigt, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe. Und im Web nochmal extra. Ich habe da generische Daten und will die einfach mal kollaborativ mit irgendjemanden entwickeln. Das waren einfach ganz normale Stammdaten. Was machen die Leute? Machen sie Excel-Sheets, die sie auf den Webserver legen oder gehen zu Google und machen sich da einen Spreadsheet auf?
Vorwass zum Beispiel, alles Mögliche.
Filemaker, Sassos. Das ist alles total anstrengend. Aber der Bedarf ist eigentlich dafür da.
Ich habe das noch nicht verstanden.
Und du meinst, dass Plone an der Stelle wirklich eine Lücke füllen kann?
Ein Teil der Lücke, eine Nische. Es gibt Leute, deren Ansprüche genau damit out of the box erfüllt werden.
Kann man denn jetzt wirklich ohne fancy weitere Module eine Maske schaffen, wo ich sagen kann, ich kann selber als User neue Felder hinzufügen, die einen bestimmten Datentyp haben? Und dann habe ich da irgendwie so einen Rekord?
Das ist noch nicht wirklich brauchbar. Das ist auch in der Mache. Es gab ein älteres Produkt für Plone 2, das so etwas versprochen hat. Das war dann aber auch so spröde geworden. Das war ein guter Ansatz. Das ist aber, muss man sozusagen als...
Okay, also es könnte da sein, aber es ist da nicht.
Und es gibt halt riesen Bedarf, aber das dauert halt eine Weile. Was wir auch machen wollen, ist, dass die Plone Foundation die Schirmherrschaft für solche Pledges übernimmt. Also das ist ja etwas, wo man sagt, ich möchte Feature X haben und wenn noch genügend andere Leute auch Geld beisteuern, dann verspreche ich, dass ich hier meine 10 oder 50 oder 100 Euro beitrage. Und wenn genügend Leute das auch wollen, dann werfen wir diese Kilo Euro auf einen Entwickler, der sich dann dafür bereit erklärt, das umzusetzen. Das hat es ad hoc bereits schon ein paar Mal gegeben. Irgendwie haben wir, glaube ich, auch 4.000 Dollar gespendet, um das Plone for Artists auf Plone 3.0 läuft. Und das soll jetzt noch ein bisschen formalisiert werden. Da gibt es jetzt auch einen Plipp dafür, dass auch so etwas vielleicht mit dem offiziellen Segen, also wo man sagen kann, okay, ich gebe diesem Projekt gerne mein Geld, weil das ist sozusagen nicht nur ein...
Okay, noch weitere Beispiele, für wen das jetzt ist. Also ich meine, das mit der Desktop-Data-Base ist jetzt ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, aber wo würdest du jetzt einfach sagen, das ist so perfect fit? Also wer sollte überhaupt gar nicht mit irgendwas anderem anfangen als Plone?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das muss ich aber hier anzackzack...
Also wenn ihr jetzt keine genaue Gruppe... Du kannst ja mal umreißen, was das Profil einer solchen...
Ich gehe gerade umreißend in meine Kundenliste durch und warum die sich dann eigentlich dafür entschieden haben. In der Regel ist es natürlich, wenn man das so kennt, die wenden sich an jemanden, dem sie in solchen Fragen vertrauen und wenn der denen einen Plone empfiehlt, dann machen die das auch, wobei ich auch schon mal...
Ja gut, aber du hast ja gesagt, du empfiehst es jetzt auch nur noch, wenn es passt irgendwie. So gehst du jetzt vom Nagel aus. Was ist die Struktur einer Organisation und was ist sozusagen Ihr Web-Publikationsbedarf, wo die Sachen zusammenkommen? Ich meine, ein paar Sachen kann ich jetzt schon selber herleiten aus dem, was wir gesagt haben, wenn da mehrere Leute den Content pflegen sollen. Ich meine, die Grundannahme eines Content-Management-Systems ist klar. So, ich würde jetzt auch sagen, das Ding kriege ich jetzt nochmal ein extra Blümchen, wenn sozusagen Sicherheitsprobleme von vornherein auf Basis von Zugriffsrechten möglichst solide verhindert werden sollen. Ja, da mögen auch andere Systeme was haben, aber wenn das schon auf dieser Sobebene quasi schon greift, dann kann sozusagen auch ein verprogrammierendes Anwendungsprogrammierer für die Spezialanwendung da nicht unbedingt so weit tragende Auswirkungen haben, wie man das eben viel zu häufig hat. Was kommt noch dazu?
Ich glaube, eigentlich macht es sogar Sinn, wenn man es umgekehrt definiert. Erstmal würde ich sagen, Plone ist toll für alle, die irgendwas im Web veröffentlichen wollen. Mit der Einschränkung, zum Beispiel, wenn ich einfach, der Kontext es nicht hergibt, dass ich zum Beispiel nur so ein 5-Euro-Hosting habe, wo ich halt nur PHP-Skripte installieren kann. Also Plone ist ein Application-Server. Das ist ein Prozess, der ständig läuft, der verbraucht RAM. Also 100 Megabyte sollte man dem schon, wenn der sich warmgelaufen hat, spendieren. Die Ressourcen sollte man haben. Das ist, man mag da vielleicht drüber schmunzeln als Nerd, aber für viele Leute ist das auch ein K.O.-Kriterium. Die haben wirklich nur, die sind vielleicht ein Verein oder haben entsprechend einfach nicht die Ressourcen, sich dann halt so etwas, so ein Hosting dann halt irgendwie anzugedeihen.
Gibt es denn Hoster, die so...
Es gibt zunehmend mehr Hoster. Es gibt jetzt einen im deutschsprachigen Raum, die sitzen im Vorarlberg. Das ist die Web-Meisterei. Ich tu die jetzt mal schamlos, einfach Schleichwerbung, weil ich die Jungs kenne und die sind sehr fit.
Das heißt, da kann man mit seinen Plonenanwendungen...
Ich hab mir das auf meinem Powerbox zusammengeklickt und das geht man denen in die Hand. Und die sorgen dafür, dass die PS auf die Straße kommen. Das gibt es jetzt zunehmend. Das ist natürlich aber auch schon eine höhere Dienstleistung, als wenn ich mir bei Strato für 2,99 Euro so eine Web-Paket-Basis klicke. Das heißt, da muss man wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen mehr investieren. Ich persönlich löse das so, dass ich für meine Kunden das Hosting mit übernehme. Das lohnt sich aber auch nur, weil die sozusagen handverlesen sind.
Ich denke, die Zuhörer von Chaos Radio Express gehen ja eher autonom.
Auf jeden Fall, kann ich ja umfehlen. Das ist auch keine große Sache. Es gibt mittlerweile sehr bequeme Skripte, um so ein deploymentfähiges Ding aufzusetzen. Mit einem Aufruf wird dann noch ein Warnisch mit installiert und ein paar halbwegs vernünftige Default-Regeln. Mittlerweile fällt das alles auch raus.
Wird denn das Plonen oder das Zope vielleicht sogar schon Benutzungsstatistiken ab?
Das fällt noch gar nicht abgegrast. Da gibt es aber auch Bedarf, weil ständig nur AV-Stats anzugucken, das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Vor allem viele Leute müssen sich jetzt irgendwie verbiegen und benutzen dann halt irgendwelche Statistikträcker. Du kennst sie wahrscheinlich besser als ich. Da zahlt man halt irgendwie so la la. Die haben natürlich auch so ein bisschen das Problem, dass man exportiert sozusagen sein Benutzerverhalten an irgendeinen Dienstleister. Der kann ja dann noch so sehr Stein und Bein schwören, dass das alles ganz anonym und geheim ist. Aber manchmal muss es dann eben auch noch ein bisschen anonymer und geheimer sein, als ein externer Dienstleister das überhaupt bereitstellen kann. Da ja der Vorteil eines solchen Web-Application-Framework, das wenn es eben jetzt mal nicht alles durch den Apache durchgeht, dass der ja ein Prinzip jeden einzelnen...
Der sitzt an der Quelle.
Der weiß ja alles, ja. Der könnte einfach ein extrem elaboriertes Profil rauswerfen, da drüber was da läuft.
Mit dem Komponenten-Modell von Soap3 und dem Event-Modell, das wir da haben, hast du eigentlich auch alle Werkzeuge an der Hand, dich da abzugreifen.
Ach, zweiter Verbesserungsvorschlag. Ist ja wie eine DDR hier.
Du bist vielleicht lobend erwähnt, als Blip-Autor. Man muss, um solche Blips erstellen zu können, du loggst dich einfach bei plone.org ein, lässt dir einen Benutzer, meldest dich selber an und kannst dir dann da so einen Teil einreichen. Man muss da nicht irgendwie zum harten Kern gehören, um Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Jetzt habe ich dich, glaube ich, zum wiederholten Mal irgendwie aus der Spur gebracht. Also ist für alle so, man muss halt einen dedizierten Server haben oder man muss sich einen passenden Hosters suchen, von dem es nicht so viele gibt?
Noch nicht, genau. Das andere ist, wenn meine Anwendung sehr speziell ist, man sollte nicht versuchen, Plone mit Riesenaufwand in einen dedizierten Application-Server zu biegen. Ich hatte auch einen Fall, über den ich leider nicht konkret reden kann, wo war hinterher fest, am Schluss war klar, das ist gar kein CMS, was wir da brauchen, das ist eine dedizierte Anwendung, die muss eine Sache gut können und schnell können, und da hatten wir dann so viel Ballast mit und haben dann ständig gegen Plone und Zope angekämpft, weil wir eigentlich noch was ganz anderes damit machen wollten. Die Anwendung sollte grundsätzlich damit zu tun haben, dass man Dokumente hierarchisch gemeinsam verarbeiten will. Natürlich könnte man auch Twitter in Plone implementieren, aber das wäre halt einfach ein Kategorienfehler. Da sollte man sich vorhin nochmal drinnen fragen, wie CMS-lastig ist mein Anliegen überhaupt? Und wenn die beiden Sachen gegeben sind, gibt es wirklich keinen Grund, warum man das nicht tun sollte.
Wenn wir jetzt nichts Großartiges vergessen haben, schauen wir mal kurz auf meine tolle Liste. Hier sind überall Haken. Fällt dir noch irgendwas Wichtiges ein, was du der Außenwelt mitteilen möchtest im Kontext unserer Ausführungen? Irgendwas haben wir vergessen. Wir hatten ja auch wieder ein kleines technisches Malheur, von dem ihr natürlich wieder alle nichts mitbekommen habt. Aber wenn wir irgendwas doppelt erzählt haben, dann könnte es daran liegen, dass mein scheiß iPod mittendrin angefangen hat, rumzustreiken. Aber, wie auch immer, wenn ihr noch Anmerkungen habt, könnt ihr das natürlich gerne tun. Im Eintrag in unserem Blog, blog.chaos.radio.cc.de, und hier haben wir das Elend. Ich habe sozusagen die drei Funktionalitäten in drei verschiedenen Systemen. Ich habe meinen Blog, meinen Podcast-Portal, meinen Wiki. Alle drei tun ihre Sache sehr gut. Das alles in ein einziges System zu bekommen, das wäre mal ganz schön. Aber da habe ich sozusagen die goldenen Hände noch nicht.
Das ist auch ein Beispiel für eben, wenn ich wirklich nur Wiki-Funktionalität brauche, dann würde ich Plone auch nicht empfehlen, weil das ist kein gutes Wiki. Ich habe zwar auch Wiki-Funktionalität, aber wenn ich nur das brauche, dann kann ich mir den Rest sparen. Auch wenn ich nur einen Blog haben will, es gibt den planet.plone.org, wo die ganzen Blogs dazu sind. Ich würde mal sagen, grob die Hälfte läuft auf WordPress oder so.
Aber ein gutes Podcast-Portal, da ist definitiv noch Bedarf, weil da gibt es für meinen Bedarf eigentlich herzlich wenig, also wie auch immer. Kommentare bitte an chaosradio.ccc.de, wenn ihr lieber E-Mails schickt oder ein Kommentar in unser tolles Blog reinschreiben. Ist immer gerne gesehen. Und das war es, Chaos Radio Express 78. Vielen Dank, Tom, für die ausführliche Ausführung. Ich hoffe, dass wir euch Soap und Plone etwas näher gebracht haben. Ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt noch eine ganze Menge begriffen, das von vorher noch nicht so klar war. Und ein paar Sachen müssen wir noch mal genauer anschauen, weil das gefällt mir ganz gut.
Das ist ja das bestmögliche Ergebnis.
Ja, das bestmögliche Ergebnis wäre, dass sich Chaos Radio cc.de auf Plone umstellt. Aber ich glaube, da sind wir noch weit von entfernt. Aber gucken wir mal. Man weiß ja nie, auf jeden Fall, wildcomputer.ccc.de ist die günste Geburt.
Genau, der fiel Fuß in der Tür.
Das muss jetzt laufen, zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieses Podcasts.
So, ich gehe dann mal weiter.
Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir machen es jetzt einfach kurz. Tschüss und bis bald bei Kraus Radio Express.